the following is a conversation with
diana walsh basulka
a professor of philosophy and religion
at uncw
and author of american cosmic ufos
religion and technology this book is one
of the most
fascinating explorations of the
interconnected nature of technology
belief and the mystery of alien
intelligence
quick mention of our sponsors element
electrolyte drink
grammarly writing plugin business wars
podcast
and cash app so the choice is health
grammar knowledge or money choose wisely
my friends
and if you wish click the sponsor links
below to get a discount and to support
this podcast
as a side note let me say as i did in
the recent video
on how many intelligent alien
civilizations are out there
that the nature of alien life
intelligence
and how they might communicate with us
humans is likely stranger than we
imagine
and perhaps stranger than we can imagine
what is most fascinating to me is how
the belief
in the communication with such
civilizations changes
people's understanding of the world and
as diana argues
the technology we create technological
innovation itself
seems to manifest the mythology in our
collective intelligence
that turns the seemingly impossible into
reality
just a matter of years through the
belief of individual humans
that carry out that innovation the
nature
and power of this belief in both
technology and extraterrestrial
intelligence
is mysterious and fascinating perhaps
holding the key to us humans
understanding our own mind
our consciousness and engineering
versions of it
in the machines we create if you enjoy
this thing
subscribe on youtube review it on napa
podcast
follow on spotify support on patreon or
connect with me on twitter
alex friedman and now here's my
conversation
with diana walsh basalka
you are a scholar of religious belief or
belief in general
so the fascinating question uh what do
you think is the difference between
our beliefs and objective reality
what is real period sure what is real
easy question so first let me start with
belief
so belief is generally there are
different
definitions of belief just just as there
are different definitions of what is
real
okay so for belief in my field it would
be
attitudes toward something that dictate
our actions
okay so we believe the sun is going to
rise tomorrow
therefore we act as if it will rise
tomorrow all right
beliefs can be wrong for a long time
people believed and actually some still
do that the earth
was flat okay well that's obviously an
erroneous belief
so beliefs can be wrong
now the bigger question that
philosophers ask is um is this belief
accurate toward
what we consider to be objective reality
so now let me go to objective reality so
what is real
i don't think we can actually obtain
a correct understanding of what is real
and in that sense i have to refer to a
philosopher again
and that would be emmanuel kant so
emmanuel kant is
one of the he was uh
basically in the 1750s he wrote
critiques of reason and things like that
so he said well if you're a philosopher
or have any kind of understanding of
western history you know who he is
um he had this idea that we can actually
never get to the thing in
itself okay so he called that the
numenol the thing in itself
he said this let's take this table for
instance that you and i are talking
across
so this thing is a table you and i both
know that
we assume it's real we believe in it
because we put our water on it and our
water stays on it okay
um however can we know this thing um in
and of itself as a table
um so that would be what he then would
call
um the phenomenal how do we know that
that phenomena exists
as we know it is okay how do we know
we use our faculties so we use our
senses and things like that but
again even our census can be wrong so
i've been on committees just recently
this year
last year for hiring professors in my
department who
are philosophers and every and we're
hiring metaphysicians and
you know people who are thinking about
the nature of reality and basically what
what i've learned from them yeah they're
very loved to attend those faculty talks
metaphysics professors what's funny is
that right for each one of them
i'm convinced each time they all say
different things but they're so
convincing i'm like yes
hire that one right is it like
historical philosophy no particular type
of no they're they have an actual belief
they're practicing
facilities yes so what they do is they
come
and they're usually excellent
philosophers from
harvard or you know usc or whatever you
know they come
and they give what's called a job talk
that's what floss well
every academic does a job talk in order
to get it they talk to
us about a department about what they do
and so
it so happens that we need him as
metaphysician and now we're hiring again
for one
and so i've i've learned a lot about
metaphysics in the last year
and this is what i've learned um that
they use
physics as a basis for understanding
what
we can know about what is real and what
is real
is really difficult to pin down and so
your question is what is belief
well belief does it correspond to
reality that's the question i would ask
and first we don't even know what is
real so the table they would say how do
we know that the table even exists well
how do we differentiate it from the
floor for example so these are the
questions that philosophers are asking
no one else is of course but
philosophers are asking these questions
and they have different answers for it
so i would say that it's very difficult
to know
what is real and in fact what i do
usually is i
paraphrase my friend and colleague
brother guy consolmano
he's a jesuit priest he's also an
astronomer and he's the director of the
vatican observatory
and so he says this he's a very smart
person he says well
truth is a moving target you know so
so basically to know what is
real out there like gravity or something
like that you've got to approximate it
and as human beings you know we have um
senses
to tell us what at least so we don't get
hurt you know we're not going to fall
off
building or something like that we have
eyes to see and things like that so
we can approximate what reality is but
we're never going to get
to it um unless we develop better senses
okay
and i think that that is what we are in
the process of doing we're developing
better senses
we have telescopes we have microscopes
we have you know extensions of ourselves
which are now called technology and we
can get to
a better understanding of what reality
is and what the objective world is and
therefore our beliefs can be honed
so we can get better beliefs more
accurate beliefs but can we get beliefs
that actually correspond to reality
um not in any precise way
but in approximate ways so i hope that's
not like too
big an answer to your question what do
you think beliefs are in themselves can
become reality
i mean so you've now adapted the
in this little bit of a conversation
adapted the
metaphysician view of reality which is
the physics
yes but you know we humans kind of
operate in the space of ideas
very much so like we've kind of in the
collective intelligence of human beings
have come up with a set of ideas that
persist in the minds of these many
people and they become quite
strong and powerful like in terms of
like impact on our lives
they can have sometimes more impact than
this table does than the physics yeah
and in that sense is is there some sense
in which our beliefs
are reality even if they're not
connected to
physics yes even if they're not real
yeah even if okay
so yes absolutely so um
our beliefs are tremendously they uh
they create social effects
absolutely um there was a belief that
i'm gonna use this example uh-oh there
was a belief back in the day
and we're talking about when i say back
in the day i'm a historian so i'm
talking about like a thousand years ago
right that women had no souls okay so
look i don't know if
human beings have souls i can tell you
this though that if human beings have
souls probably
animals do too that's my own personal
belief that's not a professor belief
there
um but there was this belief among the
catholic
uh magisterium which is runs europe
that women had no souls so they had to
have this big meaning about it you know
did women have souls
but that belief had consequences for
women
i mean women were treated and have been
treated
as if they didn't have souls um okay so
there's and the soul was
really the essence of the human being it
was it's the it's called the animus
right it's what is the
the essence of what is eternal you know
when
women were eternal here's another
example okay this is an example from my
own research
all right so there in the catholic
tradition there's this idea
of purgatory hell and heaven
and these are three destinations that
people can go to
when they die and if you're great you go
to heaven automatically and you're
considered a saint
if you're okay you go to purgatory right
and you suffer for a time and then get
back into heaven
um if you're terrible you go to hell
right okay well there was a
place that the catholics determined and
this
this was a belief for a long time like a
thousand years
or more and it was called limbo all
right
and limbo comes from the latin limbus
and it means edge
and it was either on the edge of hell or
on the edge of heaven
no one really could determine which it
was no historians are like well this
person says it was
on the edge of heaven well listen um
this was a terrible
first of all there is no limbo anymore
in 2007
um benedict the then pope got rid of the
idea
that there was limbo okay so catholics
kind of went crazy because they didn't
really know they forgot that limbo
existed and they thought it was
purgatory
and they said how could you get rid of
purgatory but actually he just got rid
of this idea of limbo oh so that's a
distinct
thing from purgatory it was by the way
people should know they have a book on
purgatory that came before your uh
american cosmic yes i wrote a book on
purgatory yeah anyway so limbo is a
distinct thing from purgatory
yeah and the the the types of people who
go
to limbo happen to be virtuous pagans
okay like socrates or somebody like that
um
and children who weren't baptized so
think of this
think of for that like more than a
thousand years
mothers and fathers gave birth to babies
who weren't baptized
and couldn't be buried with their family
in these
burial and you know they then they
couldn't be reunited with them in heaven
think of the pain as suffering that that
caused and that was
nothing limbo's nothing yet the belief
in it
caused untold suffering and that's just
a small example
and that was as real to them it was
absolutely real
i mean the effects were real let's put
it that way the place itself
not real but the families themselves do
you think they really believed it
they totally believed it the table is
real
yes i've read but listen we have trigger
warnings
today right so don't read this it's
going to make you upset okay
history primary sources no trigger
warnings okay
so you're going through like you know
somebody's diary from
1400 and you hear the suffering and pain
that they went through
there were times in my research where
i'd have to put
my primary source down you know and just
basically go outside and take a walk
because it was so horrific i knew it was
true because they wouldn't write
something you know they're not gonna
write in their diary something that's
not true and it was horrible so yes
these people went through
untold suffering for nothing for you
know because they had an erroneous
belief
but they didn't know it was erroneous so
it's real to them yeah
uh so i don't know if you're familiar
with donald hoffman
he has uh this idea that in terms of
uh the distance we are from being able
to know the reality which is there
the physics reality is we're actually
really really really really far away
from that
yeah so like it's uh i think his idea is
that
we're basically like completely detached
from it
yes uh what what's your sense how close
are we to the reality
we'll talk about him a bunch of ideas
about
our beliefs in technology and and beyond
uh but in terms of what is actually real
from a physical sense how close are we
to understanding that
pretty far i'm going to use examples
from what i do
okay so this idea that
we're suspicious of what we actually
think is real
is not new of course it goes back a long
time thousands of years in fact
and philosophers i i'm not actually
technically a philosopher but
i was one i'm a i'm a professor of
religious studies
yeah what do you introduce yourself at
like at a bar when the bartender asks
what do you do i never tell people what
i do
especially on airplanes it's a bad idea
okay so
generally if they push though i say you
know i'm the chair of philosophy and
religion
although i stepped down last year so i'm
no longer the chair
but um i i've i have like a master's
degree in philosophy and i was a
philosophy major and i've studied a lot
i still
study philosophy so i integrated into my
research
um all right so this idea that
we can't know uh we're suspicious of
what we know it's called
external world skepticism that's the
official philosophical name for it
um our faculties and our senses don't
give us accurate perceptions
of what is there okay especially at a
quantum level or a molecular
level i mean that's just obvious so yes
so i think that you're
the person you mentioned is correct in
that i think we're far away from it
i think you're talking about our direct
senses but you know we have tools
measurement tools from microscopes to
all the tools of astronomy cosmology
it gives us a sense of the big universe
and also the sense of the very small
do you think there's some other things
that are completely sort of
other dimensions or
there's ideas of pan psychism that
consciousness permeates all matter
that that's there's like fundamental
forces of physics we're not even
aware of yet like oh absolutely
i do think and this is why i write about
technology and
um i i mean that's actually what i
specialize in
is belief in technology with respect to
religion
so in my opinion thank
goodness for think for technology
because where would we be without it i
mean frankly i think that
it's like marshall mcluhan was the
person who said
technology is like an extension of our
senses
and i absolutely believe that to be true
i think that we're lucky
that we you know that prometheus gave us
technology okay
and that we use it and we're making it
better and better and better and better
and that makes us more efficient it
makes us more efficient as a species
and like my point is
is that i think that our instruments i
mean
i don't want to be a religious
technologist you know
but our our uh our instruments will save
us
i mean they're already making life
better for us you think it's important
that they also help us understand
reality more directly
more deeply i think directly as a is
better than deeply i think directly more
directly is probably
a more accurate term for what you're
trying to i think
ask me you know can we actually i mean i
think you're asking me that question
that kant basically was trying to get at
was
can we know the thing in itself can we
know that can we have like some kind of
like
intense knowing of it it's almost
mystical
um and i would say that
that's where religion comes in okay
that's where we talk about religion
um and if i may also go back to emmanuel
kant
this idea that he just before he died
just as he died he was working on he did
this critique of reason
where basically he believed he he
basically
um talks about can we know what's real
he basically has this long you know
that question can we know it's real and
then you know a thousand pages later
no i'll just give you the rundown okay
so okay yeah yeah exactly um then he
does this other
uh critique and um okay so he does like
three critiques
then he does this critique of judgment
okay well judgment is this other thing
altogether
and i think that that's what you're
getting at so how do we know things how
can we know things
really intensely and intimately and i
think that he thought that judgment
was the idea that we can actually
um know the thing in itself and he was
working on that
as he died and then he never finished it
hannah arendt
another philosopher of the 20th century
took it up
took up the critique of judgment and
tried to finish it
oh why the word judgment because
judgment think about it
when you see a work of art who judges
that to be
decent okay so there's a there is um
a group of people who come to the
decision that
that's rotten or you know that's pretty
good
you know like um i noticed that you like
to play guitar
well you choose music that i happen to
like too okay
so you and i both have a you know sense
of judgment it's a sense
so he said there's a sense that some
people have
why do certain communities have a
similar sense
what what dictates that and so he was
working on that he thought it had
something to do with
the knowledge the intimate knowledge of
the thing in itself um
yeah so another um philosopher that
philosophers actually don't like at all
but religious studies people do is
martin heidegger so martin heidegger
has some great essays one is called what
is a work of art
and again he gets to you know he talks
about van gogh and van gogh's shoes you
know that picture the
the painting van gogh shoes it's really
a really intense picture
it's just shoes it's you know it's but
it's a
it's an amazing painting of shoes and i
think everybody can agree
that's a cool picture of shoes right and
so why
you know the question is why is that a
cool picture of shoes you know what kind
of
knowledge are we accessing to determine
that
indeed that that works right and in fact
we still like it
so basically the the nature of knowledge
and what does it represent
it can operate in the space of that's
detached from reality
or can it ultimately represent reality
i guess that's the is that that's the
space of metaphysics
is that is that yeah so what can we know
is actually called epistemology
but metaphysics is is basically
what is the nature of reality right and
those intersect
absolutely yeah a lot of things
intersect in philosophy we just have
fancy names for them another
non-philosopher
that may be considered a philosopher
since we're talking about reality is ayn
rand
and her philosophy of objectivism
what are your thoughts on her sense
of taking this idea of reality calling
her philosophy objectivism
and uh kind of starting at the idea that
you really could know everything and
it's pretty obvious
and then from that you can derive an
ethics about how to live life
like what is the what is the good
ethical life and all
the virtue of selfishness all that kind
of stuff uh
so you talk to a lot of academic
philosophers so i'd be curious to see
from the perspective of like
is she somebody that's uh
taken seriously at all uh
why is she dismissed as i see from my
distant perspective
by serious philosophers and also like
your own personal thoughts of like is
there some interesting bits
that you find uh inspiring in her work
or not okay so i'm rand
um i've had so many exceedingly
intelligent
students basically
give me her books and basically say
please
dr basulka read this book and i'll tell
them yes
thank you i've read this book before and
then want to engage in
you know let me put it this way they're
religious about
ein rand okay so to them ayn rand
represents some type
of way of life right her
objectivism um now why is she not taken
seriously
by philosophers in general well let me
put it this way
um philosophers in general tend to get
pretty
i guess you could call it they're
they're s
kind of scientists but with words i
always call philosophy
when i describe it to someone who's
going to take a philosophy class i say
it's basically math problems like word
math problems
okay so that's basically what it is so
they take words very seriously and
they're very formal
and definitions very seriously yeah so
they all want to get on the same page so
they're not so there is no confusion
so for ein rand to basically say you can
know everything
and you know and establish ethics from
that i think philosophers
automatically say no now that doesn't
mean i say no
um in fact we even we have at my
university a wonderful business school
and when you walk into the the uh dean
of the business school's office ein rand
is everywhere
so it's so i want to say that not all
academics are anti-iran um
and in fact i don't think philosophers
are either except that they don't teach
ein rand okay so in one one sense you
could say
that because they don't teach her
they're being exclusive in what they
teach
or very particular perhaps is another
way to put it
yeah it's hard to know where to place
people like her because um
you know do you put albert camus as a
philosopher so
i guess what's the good term for that
like literary philosophers
or whatever the term is it's annoying to
me
that the academic philosophers get to
own the word philosophy
because like it's just like people who
think deeply about life
is what i think about is philosophy and
like
to me it's like all right so i know
nietzsche
is another person that's probably not
respected in the philosophy circles
because he is you know full of
contradictions full of uh
i love nietzsche he's just my favorite
philosopher
oh really yes i absolutely love
nietzsche so he's definitely
you know i i love people that are full
of ideas even if they're full of
contradictions and nietzsche
absolutely and iran is also that
i'm able to um look past the obvious
ego that's there on the page and uh
the fact that she actually has in my
view a lot of wrong
ideas uh but there's a lot of
interesting tidbits to pick up
and uh the same same goes with nietzsche
and
i'm i'm weirded out by the religious
aspect here
on both the people who like worship iron
rand
and people who completely dismiss her i
i just kind of see as
oh can we just read a few interesting
things and get inspired by it and move
on
as opposed to no have a dogmatic
is there something you find about her
work that's interesting to you
um or her personality or any of that
oh i think she's fascinating um i don't
dismiss her
um she was a woman who reached a level
of success
with her mind at a time when that was
difficult so
i mean she's definitely um worth looking
at
for for even that reason um but also um
her idea i guess part
of the situation with rand first of all
i think that
um her work is you have to
it's misinterpreted okay and i think
that's the same with nietzsche
like a lot of people think that i mean
in fact
it is the case that nietzsche's writing
before the 20th century so he's got that
you know he's
somewhat his rhetoric is
sexist and racist and you know of the
time period
right he was a educated
philosopher of that time period however
um his books are amazing
and nietzsche's philosophy is incredible
and i think that i think that's what
you're
saying about rand too and i agree i mean
i think that
that um we get caught up i mean
likely we should and we should
contextualize these thinkers
in the time period within which they are
we should not forgive
their you know because there were people
during nietzsche's time that
were you know uh feminist and and not
racist and things like that and
you know so but uh each has
mary i mean i would say nietzsche is and
i you did ask me to talk about some of
the books that made the largest impact
on me
and the nietzsche's gay science is one
of them it's one of the best books
ever in my opinion i do think nietzsche
was uh
i don't know about exactly sexist he
certainly was sexist but
it felt like he didn't get laid much in
his life
no it felt like he was extra sexist
i was like his theories on women are
like all right he's pretty angry
he seems frustrated yeah like all right
calm down buddy uh the fate of
philosophers
i just ignore everything he just says
about women
[Laughter]
so can we can we talk about myth and
religion a little bit
yes i mean can we start at the beginning
which is like
myths how are they born
there's this collective intelligence
amongst us human beings and we seem to
create these
beautiful ideas that captivate the minds
of millions
how is such a myth born great question
okay so that brings us to terminology
again
in um in my field we
we definitely i think try not to
distinguish between religion i this is
going to be
controversial i think between religion
and myth because
we call other cultures religions
myths right and then we call our myths
religions and i guess myth has a bad
connotation to it that it's not
real yeah now what's interesting is that
um people like plato who lived thousands
of years ago 2
500 about um basically made this
distinction himself within his
own culture which was greek right
so plato's a very famous greek
philosopher
and he would say things like this he
would say that um
he would make a distinction between the
reality
of the one god or the one he would call
it
he didn't call use the word god but he's
referencing a divinity of
okay and he believes in the soul okay
so but he would also say that the gods
and goddesses of the greeks are just
myths
so even he would make that distinction
again you know
he would say the population is not too
bright so they believe in
these gods and goddesses but he himself
is talking to
his students and he's basically talking
about
forms you know so you know there that
live and
seem to live in these other dimensions
like this table let's go back to this
table that we're talking
um around right now he would say that
this table is the instantiation of the
form
table and that there is this table that
actually exists somewhere
it's where this place where numbers
exist like the number two
okay so there we use the number two
mathematically therefore it exists
but have you ever seen a real one have
you ever seen the real two
no no okay so but where does it exist so
he says that tables
so he was also talking about things that
you know
he says are real making a distinction
between
the people and and by the way he got
this from socrates is
his um mentor who was killed by athens
because
he would say such things people don't
like to be told that they
what they believe in is not real right
yeah by the way his idea of forms
is just he's just making me realize how
like incredible was that
somebody like that was able to come up
with that i mean that idea became a myth
that
the idea of forms right that permeated
uh
probably the most influential set of
ideas in
in the history of philosophy in the
history of ideas
yes yeah i mean plato we know him for a
reason right
yeah so let's say that we're not
it's a gray area between religious and
myths and maybe not even
it is gray yeah uh so what how's that
idea with like little plato
start and permeate through all of
society oh how does it happen okay so
there are different ways that religions
work
um so a lot of people would call the ufo
narrative today
like uh and this is what i talk about in
my book like a myth
right the ufo myth but a lot of people
believe in it okay
so how do these things work well what i
did was i took
um there's a ann taves at
um uc santa barbara she's a pretty
well-known academic
who studies religion and she has this
building block
definition of religion like it builds
okay and so
she says there are there's there are no
religious experiences
or mythic experiences there are
experiences
and then they get interpreted as
religious
or mythic okay and so i i use that
with the ufo narrative so i take
um and i compare it to the religious
narrative so basically what happens
um what happens is this is that a person
generally has a very
intense experience um it could be with
something that they see in the sky
a being you know that they see um you
know like moses in the burning bush or
something like that
they tell other people okay and those
other people believe them because
they say that guy let's take you okay
alex
okay so you're playing you know some of
your music
jimi hendrix shows up out of the blue so
jimi hendrix who's
who does electric church stuff right the
electric church movement
so he shows up i was i'm sorry for a
small attention i was
i'm not aware of i apologize if i should
be
i'm just know how to play all of the
songs
uh electric church is this
oh yeah yeah it's jimi hendrix's thing
yeah
so that was like a philosophy of his or
what yes yes so he thought he was it was
like a mission for him like
like he was a missionary and he was like
doing the electric church
it was through his mission of music that
he was actually
impacting people spiritually and i think
you have to agree that his music is
really spiritual yeah
wow that's so cool to know that there's
like a philosophy there yeah i wonder if
he's ever written anything
he's spoken about it many times
interesting yeah i actually do some
some research here wow that adds another
level of depth that's awesome
okay so okay so say lex is playing
yeah 100 one of his songs he shows up
what's your favorite hendrick song by
the way
oh that's a hard one i like castles in
the sand it's a sad one but
yeah i i like it so i'm playing
something yes
i show up and also boom just like elvis
does for people
yeah hendrix shows up all right and then
you're amazed and then he tells you
something
that's very very significant and he says
you need to tell other people this okay
so then like okay i go on social media
yes
and you start and because people believe
you and because you
are a person of um you know credibility
people believe you and so all of a
sudden a movement starts okay
and it's the hendrix movement it's
hendrix ii or something like that you
know we call it something
uh the next iteration of hendrix right
hendrix lives
but he lives is this vibration and only
lex can like you know
can can manifest this vibration okay so
like
this is this is how religion starts you
know excuse your audience who are
religious i'm actually practicing
catholics so
um this is how religion starts they
start with first off a contact
experience
not i mean not all of them but a good
portion of them
um some person has an experience that's
transcendent
sacred to them and they go and they tell
other people
and then those people tell other people
and then something gets written about it
okay and then it becomes because it's a
charismatic movement
people become affected by it and if if
too many people are affected by it
um an institution steps in and tries to
control the narrative
uh so this is what you'd call the
beginning of a religion
or a myth a very powerful myth and so
it's almost like
a star right a star is born okay yeah
when you say institution do you mean
some other organization that's already
powerful
doesn't want to become uh overpowered by
this new movement
yes absolutely is this usually
governments it's usually yeah
so i have a couple examples so i use the
example of the christian church
in my book because i'm most familiar
with the history of christianity
and you know christianity you know was
started by this jewish man
and it was a movement that you know he
was a very powerful
charismatic person other people believed
in him and then his followers talked
about him
and then other then you know usually
early christians before the
300s were generally people who were
disenfranchised because he had a pretty
radical idea that you know
humans should have dignity and this was
pretty radical during that time so women
who didn't have dignity and you know
slaves who didn't have dignity at the
time
um converted christianity in droves
and so what happened was that all of a
sudden um it became
this belief system that was under
current and then
constantine who was an elite
had an experience and made christianity
a state religion
and by that time there were different
forms of christianity
probably hundreds of them well most
likely and
constantine and the people who were
powerful with him decided that their
idea
this is the council of nicaea now
decided that there was
one form and they called it universal
the one form of christianity and this
should be it
and so they they kind of took out all
the other denominations of christianity
and different forms of it
so you can see that a very very powerful
set of beliefs
put a culture on fire right
and so how did they they had to deal
with that fire somehow
and so they narrativized it they decided
how do we interpret this and they
interpreted it
as they wished but that wasn't the only
interpretation of christianity
i have another example i'm in a catholic
church
um a lot of times and i'm going to use
the
example of faustina
she's um she's a nun and she's polish
and um i think it was in the early 20th
century if not the 1800s
that she had a very powerful uh
many experiences actually of jesus and
she
saw jesus with rays coming out of his
his
heart and basically she called this his
divine mercy
and it became a devotion in poland and
it spread
the catholic church was not not into
this at all okay
and so they did everything they could to
try to suppress faustina's
influence which was growing and growing
and growing
and growing okay and so they were very
successful in trying to keep her quiet
and she died okay years later john paul
ii
polish sainted her and
created the divine mercy devotion which
is worldwide now
and millions and millions of people but
do you see how they
they you know completely controlled so
fascinating that it
uh that it just starts with a single so
like you said contact experience yeah
experience is the key word and
is your sense that those experiences
are legitimate so it's not
yes that's artificially constructed yeah
i think for the most part there are
legitimate experiences that people have
why would someone want to put themselves
through what they go through like why
would jesus want to get crucified i mean
that's a pretty nasty way to
die you know why would faustina bring
this upon herself
um the people that i meet who've said
that they've seen ufos that most of them
don't want to be known
because of the ridicule that goes along
with it so i honestly think that
you know there are people who are maybe
not stable and
would like the attention but for the
most part normal people don't want this
attention
so you mentioned building blocks uh you
didn't mention
the word god or
sort of the afterlife are those
essential
to the myth so there's a contact
experience is there some other aspects
of myth and religion which makes them
viral
which makes them spread and captivate
the imagination
of uh people yes is there a pattern to
them i think that for each era it's
different
and people have first let's talk about
the definition of religion if that's
okay because
most people assume the definitions that
we in the west are familiar with which
is that you know that of
christianity islam um judaism
you know monotheistic religions and
there are
that's not i mean those are just some
religions there are so many different
types of religions
some religions have no god at all zen
buddhism for example is a religion
that asks you to take away
your belief structures like to kind of
like in fact i would call that a kantian
type religion
right and that it's it's basically
telling you to get rid of your concept
concepts of what you think about things
so that you can actually have the
experience like you were talking about
earlier
of the thing in itself and they call
that satori
so there are people who believe you know
they try
to they call it meditations and
meditation
um and it's fairly radical actually
um in some monasteries i don't know if
they still do this but
they'll whack you on the head if you
appear to be
um not focusing and you know that kind
of thing you know they do things to
basically take
you away from your conceptions of
reality
and bring you into a state of
all that is which is what they call
satori and that has nothing to do with
god
i like this religion anything that
involves sticks and whacking in order
for you to focus better
i'm gonna have to join a monastery so
okay so this so
uh digging into definitions of religion
so like what is
what do you think is the scope that
defines
a religion oh okay so in my field we
have a
but a few different definitions of
religion as you can imagine just like
philosophers have
different definitions of what is real um
so i take this definition
and it comes from john livingston and
it's um
religion is that set of beliefs and
practices
um that determine that is inspired by a
transformative
what is perceived actually to be a
transformative
and sacred power can you say that again
yeah
so religion is a set of it's not just
belief it's also practices
it's both belief and practices because
you won't have the practices without the
belief
so you have those together okay and it's
inspired
by what is perceived because we don't
know if it's real or not
what is perceived to be of sacred and
transforming power
so perceived by the followers or is this
connected to the original sort of
experience no no it well
it's it's perceived by the followers
that's a really good definition so
and that's the governing idea is that
there's something
of great power yes perceived to be of
great power to which
you can connect yourself either
emotionally or intellectually
somehow in order to explore the world
that is beyond your own capabilities
yes and is there communication also
involved
or generally yeah yeah that's a great
definition okay
so within that falls everything that
we've uh
we've talked about so far including
technology and
um alien life and so on
do you think ultimately religion
is good for human civilization
let me uh maybe phrase it differently is
what's
religion good for okay yeah that's a
great question
thanks for asking that most people don't
ask that and i think it's
the question to ask why do we still have
religion that's the question right
because
scientists and others scholars um
humanists even thought that
there's this thing called the secular
secularization thesis and it's this idea
that the more um we progress rationally
and we have better instruments for
understanding our reality
the less religious we will be but that's
been found to be untrue
we're still very religious okay so why
why is it around
well it's adaptive in some way in my
opinion most
many people would not agree with me but
i kind of see it as an evolutionary
adaptation now think about religions
okay think about
christianity again for one um here comes
this idea
when you have this ruthless empire
called the roman empire
which litters its its roads with
crucified bodies
to let you know don't mess with us
okay all right here all of a sudden you
have this guy saying
god is love okay all right well that's
weird
okay so why why does this take off well
it takes off because we're becoming
a um a colonial power
that means we're going into other
countries we're conquering them
we are you know how do we survive
together
as as cultures that don't clash
well we have to have a belief structure
that allows us to
and i think religions function that way
frankly so these
religions help us in from us
richard dawkins meme idea it
allows us to explore space of ideas um
and that in itself is the um so it's
like evolution of ideas
and we're just a powerful tool for uh it
is for ideas
because you know if if i believe that
men have souls do they
yes they do okay
we're still trying to figure that out
you know why still
in terms of souls do believe cats don't
have souls but
we'll never we'll never uh we'll never
be able to confirm that
maybe if we get better instruments you
know the soul instrument
you need to come up with that one please
for cats yeah
not just for cats but for all animals
and people in general
you can put them in like a little you
know soul machine
and find out what's the status of their
soul
[Laughter]
that's funny i hope will become a
scientific discipline of consciousness
and consciousness is in some sense
connected to
maybe what the meaning of the word soul
used to be
and i i think it's a fascinating open
question like what is consciousness and
so on that
maybe we'll touch on in a little bit
but yeah anyway back to our religions
being adaptive
i think that christianity probably
helped us um
become better people to each other as we
moved into
a more global society and i also this it
goes along with my book which is
basically making the argument that
belief in non-human intelligence or ets
or ufos uaps whatever you want to call
them
is a new form of religion and
how does that work with the the
scientific method
do you think there's always this role of
religion as being
in his broad definition religion as
being a complement
to our sort of very rigorous empirical
pursuit of understanding reality
there's always going to be this coupling
we'll always define
redefining new eras of civilization of
what
that religion actually looks like so you
talk about technology and so on being
the modern
set of religious uh beliefs around that
is so is that always going to is religio
is religion always going to kind of
cover the space of things we can't quite
understand with science yet
but we still want to be thinking about
oh i see what you're saying that's a
great question
when you say religion i would i would
use the word religiosity
uh because i think that we're moving out
of the dogmatic types of religions into
more of a
i hate to put it this way but an x-files
type religion where we can say
i want to believe or the truth is out
there
right but we don't know that it's out
there or we don't we don't know yet
what it is but we know it's out there so
there's this um this kind of built-in
um capacity for belief and something
that we don't have evidence for
yet and that's a sort of faith so i
would say yes to that question
absolutely
i think it's adaptive in that way we're
moving into a new i mean heck
we've already moved into this culture
most people have not caught up with it
yet
i see that in the school systems you
know and i think that
um i'm hoping we can catch up fast
because really it's moving faster than
we are so i mentioned to you offline
that i'm
finishing up on the rise and fall of the
third reich
i'm not sure if you have anything in
your exploration
interesting to say but the use of
religion
by dictators or the lack of the use of
religion by dictators
whether we're talking about stalin which
is mostly a secular
i apologize if i'm historically
incorrect on this but i believe it's
secular and hitler i think there's some
controversy about how much religion
played a role in his own personal life
and
in general in terms of influencing
the using it to manipulate
the public but definitely the church
played a role
um do you have a sense of the use of
religion
by governments to control the
populations
by dictators for example or is that
outside of your
little explorations as a religious
scholar
it's not outside of my framework
absolutely not
um i think that it's done routinely
um propaganda is done routinely
especially there's nothing more powerful
than religion
to get people to act i think
i have my mother's jewish my father is
was roman catholic okay from irish
extraction
and so both um members
both both great-grandparents came here
under duress
because they were being um what would
you call it
uh there was an act of genocide on both
sides
being done by other cultures okay so on
the one hand
obviously we know about the holocaust
okay so they came the great grandparents
came here to
avoid that and they made it um on the
other hand
uh there was an english um
genocide we just have to say it of the
irish
um it was called a famine but it wasn't
one it was a staged
thing and so um millions of
irish left ireland on coffin ships is
what they called them because they
usually wouldn't get here mine happened
to get here okay
so those that's the context that i'm
coming from so in each case
for one thing irish weren't considered
you know there was catholics weren't
considered
they were considered to be terrible and
there was a lot of anti-catholic
rhetoric here in the united states
which is kind of strange because one of
the in fact the most
wealthy colonial family were the carols
in maryland and they were catholic
so when you look at the united states
our history
and you see the separation of church and
state do you want to know where that
came from
that came from those guys they convinced
george washington and thomas jefferson
i mean they couldn't vote yet they had
they had
they have their names on the
constitution
is that not a strange contradiction so
here's here you can see how
you know propaganda works there was
anti-catholic propaganda
there was anti-jewish propaganda um and
all of and a lot of it was that
you know these people weren't human they
weren't human beings
um another thing i'd like to say is that
when the irish did come here and they
were indentured a lot of times
indentured servants
um but that's a that's terminology
then what is an indentured servant
slave pretty much
so in that sense religion can be used
derogatorily yeah derogatory as a useful
grouping mechanism of saying this is the
other
and you know it's powerful too because
behind it is a force of
um you know what people can tend to be
sacred a sacred force
right so you know it's up to god
to you know decide who's you know so you
have to go along with what god says of
course
well that's basically um that's not the
contact event you know the contact event
is
is usually some type of very specific
legitimate event that a person has with
something that
is non-human or considered divine
but when when religions become
narrativized i would call it by
different institutions
that's when you're in danger of getting
propaganda
you said nietzsche one of your favorite
philosophers he said
uh famously one of the many famous
things he said
is that god is dead yes
oh what do you think he meant do you
think he was right
okay good i love this question no one
asks me about nietzsche
and i love nisha okay so um first
actually i do
think and i could be corrected and
probably will be in all the comments
yeah well first nietzsche it's true
wasn't the first to say god is dead
i think hegel said it okay no one reads
hegel he's like so
difficult to read that it's impossible
same with heidegger as you mentioned
yeah he i love him but yeah he's really
hard to read um so nietzsche
basically said god is dead and let me
give you the context for him saying that
he also said this he said there was only
one christian he died on the cross
okay so um he despised christianity
and he said that and and the people who
practice it
absolutely yeah but again he believed in
jesus and he believed jesus was
he didn't believe he was a divinity he
believed jesus was a good man
and he died on the cross okay so he
believed in the morality
yeah he absolutely did yeah he did um
and
nietzsche basically was making a
historical statement about god is dead
he said and he was right he was
basically saying that in this in the
century in which he lived
um and he died i think in 1900 again i
could be
wrong about that so i just want to say
that i believe he died in 1900
okay so so he's writing in the 1800s and
he's basically saying
um god is dead and we killed him okay
so he's making a historical statement
that at that point in time
with science just kind of getting better
and industrialization
happening um the idea of
um this this thing beyond
what we know as material reality is dead
so this the substrate of western
civilization
is dead that's what nietzsche nietzsche
is saying
if that makes sense yes and he's
basically says with that
comes the ubermensch okay which is the
superhuman
and he says there aren't many of them he
says but they're going to come and he
also talks about the philosophers of the
future
and he's speaking and writing to them is
my belief
so he's basically telling you and me
because we're now the philosophers of
his future yeah
he's basically telling us this is what's
happening now
and look what it has done he says now
everything is is possible all manner of
terrible evil
because no one has the belief in god
anymore the belief that there's
uh that there is an afterlife you asked
about an afterlife so with this kind of
belief in
a morality comes this belief you know
you can have morals without god okay
people do
but what christianity is this idea that
you will reap what you sow so if people
don't believe that anymore what will
happen
and so that's what he's basically saying
is that the the basic
anchor for western society is now gone
do you think he was right absolutely
absolutely right
but then again what do you think if we
brought him back to life and he read
american cosmic your book um and he
wrote
he tweeted about it right
writing a review maybe for the i don't
know what they post for new york times
he'd be an
editorial writer uh with a blue check
mark on twitter
uh what do you think he would say about
this idea that you present
that's a grander idea of religion
and you know like religiosity like
yeah yeah wouldn't that kind of reverse
the idea that god is dead
yeah because it would bring up this idea
of external intelligences
that are not human which is basically a
lot of
religions talk about that right there
are bodhisattvas
there are angels there are demons you
know there's all these
types of non-human intelligences that
religion makes space for so what i'm
basically saying in american cosmic is
these new
things are within the realm of
ufos and uaps so with no i think that
well i think nietzsche would say that
that's a progressive adaptation of
religion
is what i would hope he would say
nietzsche however
is unpredictable i think i i couldn't
predict him
so i would say that it would be my hope
that he would say
this is an accurate representation
of a move into a new type of religion
and it's adaptive therefore progressive
he would probably be uncomfortable
reading a book by a brilliant
female professor who happens also to be
short
[Laughter]
i don't know if you read that no yeah
he said some pretty nasty things about
short women oh
my god yeah i need you he should be
canceled
no no please don't cancel nietzsche you
have to take people in the context of
their time
although i'm pretty sure in his time he
was also an [ __ ] he was
but [ __ ] are people too okay just
bad ones
[Laughter]
uh you wrote the book american cosmic
ufos religion technology what was the
goal of writing this book
what uh maybe we'll mention it we have
already mentioned it
many times but in this little
space of a conversation can you say
maybe what is the key insight that you
found
that lingers with you to this day from
the process
the long process of uh putting this book
together sure
just like with my book on purgatory um
i went into the research thinking that
it would be something
that it was entirely not it ended up
being something completely different
and i think that's good i think that
people who do research
need to are very excited actually when
their research surprises them
so i was happily surprised by my
purgatory book
to learn that it was a place you know
and and so
um i went into
american cosmic being a non-believer
in ufos entirely and i came out
being agnostic okay
kind of believer
yeah so agnostic sort of uh
open to the mysteries of the world yes
and
i didn't think that first of all i knew
that the
government was was part of the
situation i just didn't know how much
and so i learned that
quickly and acclimated to it
um accepted it and
noted that indeed
horatio the world
is much more mysterious than we think
it is it's more mystery there are more
mysteries in
this life than your philosophy provides
for
so as a sense american cosmic is about
the mysteries of the modern life as
encapsulated by this
the the realm of technology in the realm
of alien
intelligences yes i think that um
i think that i mean i'd have to go
off record as a professor and talk
personally as a person
i do think that um
there are mysteries of which
we have an inkling and if it's something
as powerful as
non-human intelligence whether or not
it's from another
planet extraterrestrial or it happens to
be from
like another dimension or something else
i think that
this is going to um get the attention of
institutions of power
and indeed i think that's what has
happened and
um although probably
he people have had interactions with
these things
it appears to me historically uh for
a long time as long as humans have
existed i would imagine
that indeed um
this is something that's quite powerful
and could change the
belief structures of our entire
are civilization basically so it's the
same way that you're
talking the belief structures were
strongly affected by religious beliefs
throughout history yes in the same way
this has the potential
uh it it uh serves as um
a source of concern for the powerful
because
it can have very significant effects on
the populace
yes is there some broader understanding
of how we should think about alien
intelligences
than um like little green men yes
that that you can maybe elaborate on and
talk about
yes this comes directly out of my
research in catholic history
what i found was that let's take for
instance this idea of an
angel okay so we all think we know what
an angel looks like why
well we've been told what an angel looks
like we see what an angel looks like
throughout history people have painted
angels and they all look pretty much the
same
but actually if you go to the primary
sources on
you know either in hebrew or in greek or
you know in whatever language and in
latin
and you look at experiences that people
have
talked about you know where they've
written down their experiences about
angels
um angels don't at all look like
what we think they they don't look like
little cherubs with wings
they don't look like tall you know
strong
[Music]
anthropomorphic you know human looking
things they don't they look really weird
and sometimes they don't look at all a
humanoid and they look like strange
spinning things right with like you know
eyes and things like that they
they communicate telepathically with us
okay so what does that mean for
the idea of extraterrestrials or what we
consider to be
aliens like um i do think that
they're first if we are if listen
is i'm not the first to say this if
we're in contact with
non-human intelligence we're most likely
in contact with its
technology because think about us
um do we send human beings to mars yet
some people say yes but let's put that
aside so
no we don't we use our technology we
send our rovers to mars
okay okay so if there's an
extraterrestrial
civilization is it sending are they
coming
by themselves are they coming to see us
or are they sending their technology
most likely
they either are technology or they are
sending their technology yeah there
might be a gray area between what is
technology and what the aliens are
yeah so but you're saying like uh
basically a robotic probe
that would be the equivalent of us our
human civilization created technology
way more
way more uh advanced than what we could
believe to be a probe all right it's
kind of funny to think about like
if uh whatever a sort of
um extraterrestrial creations have
visited earth that were we're
interacting with some like
dumb crappy drones yeah that's true
and we're like like
we're like building these like myths and
so on from like an experience with some
like crappy drone made by some crappy
startup something that's correct
when the actual intelligence is like
something
much grander um yeah that's that's
that's the more likely uh the situation
is that's what i like to
tell people i'm like no it's probably a
lot weirder than you think
yeah oh boy so uh
but what forms can it possibly take so
yeah okay i really love this idea that
um
i tend to be humble in the face of all
that we don't know
and i tend to believe that the form
alien life forms would take
and the way they would communicate is
much more likely
to be of a form that we can't even
comprehend or perhaps can't even
perceive directly so like
you know uh it could be in the space of
you know we don't understand most of how
our mind works it could be in the space
of whatever the heck consciousness is
like maybe consciousness itself is
communication
uh with aliens or like
i don't know uh it could be just our own
thoughts is actually the alien life
forms
communicating like i i know all that
sounds crazy but i'm saying like
i'm just trying to come up with the
craziest possible thing that doesn't
make any sense
that could very well be true and you
can't say it's not true
because we don't understand basically
anything about our mind so it can be
all of those things uh everything from
hallucinations all the things that are
explored through
uh through the different drugs that
we've uh
talked about in this podcast in general
joe rogan loves to talk about dmt and
all those kinds of
hallucigenic drugs all of it
including love and fear
all those things that could be aliens
communicating with us memes on the
internet that could be
pretty sure humor is alien communication
no i don't know
but uh so is there some way that's
helpful for you to think about
beyond the little green men oh
absolutely it um it occurs
exactly with how i think actually um so
i'll explain
um i liked in american cosmic
i attained the status of full professor
so i was like okay i can
pretty much write this book like i want
to do it and i did so i used a lot of
quotes from cool
artists like david bowie okay so david
bowie opens the book
okay and he basically says and so does
nietzsche by the way david bowie and
nietzsche
boom two two awesome quotes right
together that's how he opens up no
better opener
yeah do you remember the quotes yeah of
course so the first the
quote by david bowie and that's what i'm
gonna concentrate on in response to
what you just said which i think is
absolutely correct um david bowie said
the internet is an alien life form
okay and if you've not seen david
bowie's interview
where he says that i highly recommend it
he's so brilliant okay so david bowie is
actually quite brilliant
about the idea of ufos he's also
brilliant about the idea of technology
okay and most people wouldn't think that
but i mean he's
pretty darn smart okay so all right
so i started to think about it and uh i
also early on in my research met jacques
valet okay so he's a technologist
uh he has a phd in information
technology from
computer science basically from
northwestern and he got that back in the
day you know when i say back in the day
i'm not talking a thousand years ago
i'm talking like in the 60s okay so he's
back when computer science wasn't really
even the future yeah
you can get a degree yeah he has a phd
in it
and he's french he's from france but he
lives in silicon valley
and he worked on arpanet which is the
proto-internet
uh he mapped mars he's also an
astronomer i mean he's just this
all-round brilliant guy right
and he's also interested in ufos and
most people take
those two interests of his as separate
interests
and i remember being at a very small
conference and listening to him
being in awe of course because he's an
awe-inspiring person
and then thinking wait a minute why do
people
compartmentalize those two things about
him they're one and the same
okay so when we talk about ufos and uaps
and stuff
we have to talk about digital technology
and things like that
now if we're going back to what i
so if i were to say what if i were to
believe in
and i like i said earlier i was agnostic
boardroom on belief
most likely a believer in these this
extraterrestrial or
not extraterrestrial let me put it
another way non-human intelligence
that's communicating with us
i'm going to tell you how i think they
communicate with us and i go back to the
greeks again
okay and the greeks had this idea of
muses
you know the muses so okay so there are
these things called muses
and we tend to think of them as
metaphors right but what if they're not
or if they're actually non-human
intelligence trying to communicate with
us but we're so stupid
we can't like understand like so only
people with like you know
in super amazing um capacities like
poetic
creative you know intelligent
mathematical whatever
you know because they tend to do this
symbolically they tend to communicate
with us in symbols form
and so music you know symbols we've got
math that are you know it's a symbolic
language
and so what so okay so muses are
probably a good
idea for me of what this would be now
would muses have
spaceships you know or those things that
we call physical
counterparts to what they are um
that's another question altogether but
if you know i i
now why would i think this because if
you look at the history there are space
programs
both russian and american you're going
to find some pretty weird stuff
pretty pretty weird history there lex um
so
you want to get an idea go back to
tchaikowski and read a little bit about
what he has to say
if you look back at the history of our
space programs the viable space programs
are both russian and american
and each has an amazingly
strange history because uh the founders
of the calculations that got us up into
space the rocket scientists basically
were doing some pretty weird rituals and
doing religious things
right they weren't necessarily like jack
parsons on our side
i was out in the desert with people like
elrond hubbard and
doing really intense rituals
believing that they were opening
stargates and things like that okay
that's awesome and they were really
doing that okay
so then you go to um the russian
side and they had a very specific
non-dogmatic according to catholics or
orthodox christianity
idea of what christianity was and they
believed that they were interacting with
angels
okay non-human intelligences so if you
look back and you see muses
you know you can contextualize them
within this tradition
and so when i started to talk to people
who were actually in
the space program and who were in these
programs that
now the government has said oh yeah we
do have those programs
and they have the same belief structures
they believe that they were also in
contact with these non-human
intelligences
and they were getting what they called
downloads of information and creating
sometimes
with tyler d in my book creating
technologies
that were real and they were selling
them on nasdaq for
you know a lot of money like you know
say a hundred million dollars or
something like that
undisclosed amounts um but a lot and
these things are viable technologies
that we use now and
and they make our lives better and we
progress as a species because of them
now that has nothing to do with the
scientific method
as much as i know as much as anybody's
going to get angry at me for saying
that but you know sorry those were
strange
encounters that created our ability
to go into space i don't know if they're
real or not
but these people believe they were real
right so there's a
they have a power in actually having an
impact in this world
in um in inspiring humans to create
technology which enable us to do things
we haven't been able to do before
yeah and these i like how we we're
putting like
angels alien life forms
aliens and technology all in the
non-human intelligence camp which i i
really like that because
this that's very true
it's this other source of uh wisdom
intelligence maybe a connection to the
mysterious
yes i was really surprised by it
can you speak a little bit more to the
connection between
aliens and technology
that jacques valet had in his own
one individual mind that's very tempting
to kind of separate as
two separate uh endeavors
why did you come to believe that they
are
one and the same or at least part of the
same
uh intellectual journey thanks for
asking that again
because nobody asks me that question and
it's central to my project so
jacques was a huge influence is a huge
influence on me
um he taught me a lot um
i had he gave me access to some of his
information that's that he keeps
um but a lot of his information is
actually there out there for everyone to
read
he has an academia.edu page and he just
so he didn't have this unfortunately
when i was
doing my research in 2012 and 2013 so i
had to go back and do microfiche
type stuff you know what i did was i
began to read everything that he wrote
and he actually gave me a lot of his
books too
and he told me i remember he dropped me
off from
this is actually quite interesting if
you allow me to tell you a little story
please
okay and it also includes ayahuasca so
great every star includes a great story
okay so i was at a conference and it was
a small conference
um of very interesting people in
california on the pacific ocean
and jacques was there and um this is
actually
opens my book this is the book this is
the i
uh go i the preface to my book i go on
this ride he takes me through silicon
valley
i've lived there right my grandparents
grew up in the same place that he
raised his children in belmont and so um
but we were there with
robbie graham who's a great ufologist in
his own right
and um and film theorists
i highly recommend his work um so we
were together and he was taking us to
san francisco where i was going to meet
my brother
who is going to take me home and so he
took us on this long
journey and he talked to us and as we
got out of the car
um he gave me several of his books
and one in particular he gave me he said
read this first
i was like okay i definitely will read
that first okay so this is how the
ayahuasca figures in
so um we were i didn't take it nor have
i taken it okay so we're
at this place and um in california
and alex gray and his wife were there
and they were talking about
their experiences with psychedelics you
know he's an amazing
visionary artist okay so he he believes
that there's this
place that you can enter and he and his
wife would enter this
space with either you know ayahuasca or
lsd or something like that and they
would not talk to each other but they
would be having the same exact
experience so they would it was almost
like having the same dream
right okay so so somehow that whole
event with jacques there and them
talking about their
experiences in these realms of which
religious studies people are quite
familiar by the way because visionary
experiences are what we study
so all of this seems super familiar to
me and i recognized that
immediately that jacques
that it hit me like you know very
obvious
that ufos and these experiences
and technology all seemed
they were all uh meshed together and i
knew that i had to take them
i knew i had to read everything jacques
ever wrote and the best stuff he's
written by the way
is the st his little essays that he
wrote in the 1970s and there were
peer-reviewed essays
about the beginning of the internet and
how a lot of it was based on
um basically like
um neural connection with the internet
like somehow
psychic connection through the internet
with others and things like that so the
mind the brain is a biological neural
network there's a
uh this connection between division
neurons and so on and that's what
ultimately is able to have uh memories
and has cognitive ability and is able to
uh perceive the world and generate ideas
and those ideas are then spread on the
internet even from the very early days
to other humans so it gets
injected or travels into the brains of
other humans and that goes around in
there and then
spits out other stuff and it goes back
and forth so it's
it's nice to think of the network that's
in our mind individual mind
as i mean um very much
even deeply connected to the network
that is the connection between humans
through the internet and so in that
sense
jacques saw the internet as this as this
powerful
um as a source of power and wisdom that
is beyond our own
exactly that's external to us like a non
like you know if you could call it
autonomous ai right right it's non-human
intelligence in a sense even though
humans are a part of it
yes or we're invaded by it or you know
whatever you want to call it
yeah right just the chicken and the egg
right
so if i can go on to experience this oh
yes
yes i'm not done with that yeah so and
this is so this is where
i come to this idea that um
we're in this space we're in now a new
space of religion of religiosity
so what happens is then i and it's like
a biosphere
and i'll talk about that in a minute so
we so so jacques takes us back
we get to san francisco and my brother
who
is your straight lace person you know
army guy
and everything like that um i get into
his car and the first thing he tells me
is
i took ayahuasca and i was like what
he goes it's gonna save humanity
that's great yeah as i mentioned to you
offline i talked to matthew johnson he's
a hopkins professor on
he's a really a scholar of most
he's he's starting most drugs he's also
really deeply studied cocaine all those
stuff and
negative effects and he's focused on a
lot of positive effects of the different
psychedelics
it's kind of fascinating so i'm very
much
interested in exploring
the science of what these things do to
the to the human mind
and also personally exploring it
although it's like this weird gray area
which he he's
he's masterful at which is he's a
professor
at john hopkins one of the most
prestigious universities in the world
and
and doing large-scale studies of the
stuff
and until until he got a lot of money
for these studies
even in uh hopkins itself there's not
much
risk it's not even respect it was like
people just didn't want to talk about it
as a as a legitimate
field of inquiry it's kind of
fascinating how hesitant we
are as a little human civilization
to uh legitimize the exploration of the
mysterious
of whatever the definition of the
mysterious is for that particular period
of time
so for us now there's like little groups
of things like
i would say consciousness in the space
of like
computer science research is something
that's still like
i don't know maybe let philosophers kick
it around for a little longer
and then certainly extraterrestrial life
forms
from um in most
formulations of that problem space
uh is still the other it's still the
source of the mysterious except maybe
like
seti which is like how can we detect
signals from far away alien
intelligences
that would be able to perceive
yeah it's uh and psychedelics is another
one of those that's like
we're starting to see okay well can we
um
try to see if there's some medical
applications
of like helping you get like he does
studies of
help you quit smoking or help you in
some kind of treatment of some disease
and he's sneaking into that i mean it's
like openly sneaking into it he's doing
studies on it of like how can you expand
the mind with these tools and what can
the mind discover
through psychedelics and so on and we're
like slowly creeping into the space
of being able to explore these
mysterious questions but it's like
it sucks that sometimes a lot of people
have to die
meaning sorry uh they have to age out
like it's like faculty have a
and people have a fixed set of ideas and
they stick by them
and in order for new ideas to come in
then the
young folks have to be born with the pot
with an open mind the possibility of
those ideas and then they have to become
old enough
and get a's in school and whatever to to
uh
to then carry those ideas forward so you
know the acceptance of the
uh exploration of the mysterious takes
time it's kind of sad
it is sad i agree maybe to
go into my source of passion which is
artificial intelligence what's your
sense about um the
the possibility uh like pamela mccordick
has this quote that i like i talked to
her a couple years ago
i guess already in this podcast that
that artificial intelligence began with
the ancient wish to forge the gods
so do you think
artificial intelligence may become
the very kind of gods
that were at the center of our the
religions of most of our history
yeah there's a lot there so i'm gonna
start by addressing this idea
of artificial intelligence being
separate from human
beings okay so that i don't think that's
actually
that might happen okay i mean it's
already happened but let's put it this
way like you're talking about super
artificial intelligence like
autonomous conscious artificial
intelligence okay yeah
something with artificial consciousness
first of all i
i think she's correct okay but also
there's awesome an awesome quote um i'd
also like to bring up
this uh writer of fiction
actually i'm ted chang and his one of
his essays he writes short essays one of
them was
the basis for the movie arrival which if
you haven't seen it it's a really great
movie about
uh ufos and
it has a very creative way of proposing
an idea of how they might be able to
communicate
first of all how they appear to us
second of all how they may be
communicating with us humans exactly and
the author ted chang
has a lot i recommend his his writings
his short stories um one is very short
and it appeared as it appeared in nature
about 20 years ago and it is called
i think it's called getting eating the
crumbs from the table or something like
that and it's basically
this short essay and i hate to to do you
know to
to do a spoiler here but it if you don't
want to know what it's about
don't listen right now yeah spoil alert
yeah okay
so this is what it's about so basically
it's about human beings
uh becoming two different species okay
and one of them is created they're
called meta-humans
and they start bio-hacking themselves
with
tech okay sound familiar so they do this
and they become meta-humans and another
species
right and you know just kind of another
fork
um such that humans
can barely understand them um because
they're so far
removed so in a sense are they
gods right no they're meta-humans
they're super humans they're enhanced
humans okay
i see that hopefully on the horizon
frankly i hope so
not that we have two species but that we
can use our technology or we can
we can become so integrated with our
technology
that we can survive okay we can survive
the radiation in space we can't go
places now because of the radiation in
space
perhaps we can develop our bodies such
that we can survive
the radiation in space so there there's
this idea of these meta-humans now
there's also this idea that technology
is just another
form of humans we've created it right
and so
maybe it is bent on surviving thereby
using us you know kind of as a meme or a
team
some people are calling them teams now
these self-generating
uh they're replicating themselves
through us
okay i see that also and i don't think
that's
terribly bad maybe it's just the way
that we
are evolving it doesn't mean that the
you know we're evolving all the time
like we're taller than we used to be you
know we have different
skills and you know so i don't see that
as
as a bad thing i think a lot of people
see it as if we're not how we are now
it's a tragedy but it's not a tragedy
how we are now is actually a tragedy
for most people alive yeah and we might
be evolving ways we can't possibly
perceive like you said that
uh the humans have created twitter
and twitter may be changing us yes
in ways that we can't even understand
now currently like
from a perspective if you look at the
entirety of the network of twitter that
might be an organism
that this now the organism understands
what's happening
from its level of perception
but we humans are just like the cells of
the human body we're interacting
individually but like we're not actually
aware of the big picture that's
happening
yeah and we naturally somehow or
whatever the force that's creating the
entirety of this
whatever uh one
one version of it is the evolutionary
process like biological evolution
whatever force that is is just creating
this greater and greater level of
complexity and maybe somehow
not other kinds of non-human
intelligence are involved
that we're calling alien intelligences
yes
so just to step back and we'll come back
to ai because i gotta i love the topic
but um
through american cosmic and in general
you've interacted with much of the ufo
community you mentioned
ufologists by the way is it
ufologists or is it ufologists it's
ufologists
you follow jesus yeah so first of all
wood is a ufologist
and second of all um what have you
learned about this
community of ufologists or else as you
refer to them as
the invisibles or the members of the
invisible college
or just in general people who study ufos
from the different
all the different kinds of groups that
study ufos sure
generally what i found is that
they are okay so people who are
interested in ufos from like
being a kid you know and seeing some
cool movie like star wars or something
and then they become interested and then
they study it as best they can
ufos or uaps they're generally
an honest group of people who are using
their tools
there are generally two types of them um
there are those who believe in nuts and
bolts like the physical craft
and they believe in that these are
things from other planets
okay so that's like the e t h hypothesis
uh you know um i'm sorry et
hypothesis eth is what we call it yeah
sorry about that
so this is like there's an actual
spaceship like a phys
like something akin but much more
advanced than the rockets we use now
yeah and uh some kind of
not necessarily biological but something
like biological organisms that travel on
these
species so this would be like what to
the stars academy
is trying to decipher like how you know
how do they do it
you know maybe we could use that
technology the propulsion and things
like that they look at the rocket
technology
okay so there are those and then there
are people who believe that it's more
consciousness-based
okay so these are your two types of um
ufologists
who are known and these are people who
we know about
then i found that there are people who
are quote unquote i call them the
invisibles
because jacques vale in the in the 70s
he and um i think actually alan hinek
his colleague
quoted this is a francis bacon thing by
the way it goes back to
the early modern time period when
scientists could be killed for basically
trying to go outside
what the church or the government
institution determined was
dogma and so they had to be really
careful so they caught he called
the invisible college so heinek took
that term
and returned reused it or what do you
call it um repurposed it
so that he repurposed it so that they
were still talking to each other though
so what i found to be the case was that
there was a group of people who were
scientists
but were not on the internet you know
people today and students of mine in
particular
and my own kids actually they think that
you only exist
if you're on the internet or something
only exists if it's on the internet and
that's of course untrue and so what i
found was that there are
most people who are the most powerful
people of our society and are doing
things
are not on the internet you're not going
to find any trace of them so
a lot of these people are what i call
invisibles people who are studying
at least their work is invisible you
might find them on the internet but
you're going to find that they're part
of the bowling league or something like
that right you will not find
that they are actually engaged in
research about
this topic okay and so i called them the
invisibles because i was surprised to
find them
and i thought well this is no longer the
invisible college
because these people are not even
talking to each other and that's why i
reference
this movie fight club in it you have an
invisible
okay and his name is tyler durden and
he's incredible he does incredible
things
um he's like a person who should not
exist
right because he does so many things
that are amazing
and so i found a person like that and i
call and he's a real person
um he's partially on the internet but
nothing that he does
around that topic of ufos is on the
internet so i decided to call him tyler
d
after tyler durden and so these people
i've turned the ufo fight club because
they work together but they don't know
in fact his boss doesn't know what he
does
they don't talk to each other because
you know the first rule of fight club
same as the second yeah exactly yeah you
don't talk people
no you don't do it why do you have a
sense that
um there's such a i don't want to say
fear but a principle of staying out of
the limelight
i think there's something real and i
think that the use of it could be
um dangerous for people oh sorry you
mean like something real like there's
actual technology i don't what's the
right terminology here to use
it alien technology
ideas about technology that are
being explored that are dangerous have
made public
that may be become dangerous so
i wouldn't cut you don't alien
technology you can call it ideas about
alien technology because
i don't know if it's actual alien
technology or not i honestly don't know
but i do know for a fact because it's a
historical fact
that jack parsons and um constantine
tchaikovsky who's russian believed in
these things and believed that they were
downloading
this information whether or not they
were i don't i mean
they definitely created the rocket
technologies that's true how they did
and whether their process was exactly
what they said it was
i don't know so this is the same thing
today so we've got some powerful
technologies going on here and you know
of course we have a military and we have
a military for a reason every
almost every government who needs a
military has one um
and so they're going to um keep these
the way they should be kept in my
interpretation i mean think about it
everybody accepts the fact that we have
a military almost everybody does
why are they so upset then that the
military keeps secrets
yeah well that's that's the nature of
things and we can get into that whole
thing i
i i tend to i've spoken with the cto of
lockheed martin on this
um i obviously read and think about war
a lot it's such a difficult
question because this space this
particular space of technology
there's a gray area that i think is
evolving over time
i think nuclear weapons change the game
in terms of
what should and shouldn't be secret i
think there's already technology that
will enable us to destroy each other and
so there's some sense in which
some technology should be made public
this is the same discussion of um
you know uh between companies which part
of
your technology should you make public
through like for example academic
publications and all that kind of stuff
like how the google search engine works
page rank algorithm or
how the different deep learning like
there's pretty vibrant
machine learning research communities
within google facebook and so on
and they release a lot of different
ideas it's an interesting question like
how dangerous is it to release some of
the ideas i think it's a gray area
that's constantly
changing i do also think it's super
interesting
i wonder if you could elaborate on a
little bit that there's this
gray area between what's actually
real in terms of alien technology
and the belief of it
when held in the minds of really
brilliant people
that they ultimately may produce the
same kind of result
in terms of being able to create new
technologies that are human usable
like is there um
in your mind they're one and the same as
like believing
in alien craft and uh
actually being in possession of an alien
craft i don't think they're the same no
belief is powerful okay um
in new age communities you know people
think
thoughts are things okay that's been
said you know thoughts are things
you can make them happen kind of thing
believe in them enough it is true that
if i believe i can run
a 540 mile i'll do it okay and i
probably will do it and i've done it
before actually
um much younger but i did it
so but my coach is the one that
instilled that belief in me right
and so but can i run like a one minute
mile
no okay so i guess does that answer your
question like there's only so far belief
goes
in generating reality well yeah i mean i
guess that's what uh
just having listened to jacques valet it
seemed like
reality is not was not as important
for the scientific exploration of the
concept of alien technology
i could be wrong but this is what i
think jacques is getting at there are
other ways to access
places in reality other than what we
consider to be physical
right that's what is consciousness okay
so in like i said so religious studies
is among other things it's it's looking
at visionary experiences
all right so people do have visionary
experiences they did without drugs
you know they did with drugs they do
with drugs they do
many have them without drugs today and
oftentimes those visionary
experiences um correspond to each other
now how do we how do we make sense of
that so you know do these places
actually
exist in a sense i think they do and so
i think that you know like let's take
that very famous case of a virgin mary
apparition in fatima
where i think there was like a lot of
people thousands and thousands
if not like i think 50 000 or something
like that a lot of people
gathered to see what's now called
um the miracle of fatima which was the
spinning of the sun
well a lot of people saw different
things but they all saw some
kind of thing okay so they all saw
different things but it was
something happened okay so i guess the
question is um what are these
places where we access
non what i'd call like non-physical
realities
okay where we actually do get
information we get like who could say
that jack parsons didn't get information
from doing these rituals
and accessing these we have to say that
he actually did
because we see the results of physical
results the same thing with tyler and
that's why i put tyler
in this camp with this tradition with
jack parsons i say that
tyler is is getting these what he calls
downloads
and you can see the results of them
physically
he sells them on the nasdaq he makes
millions of dollars from them he they
help people
i've seen people who they've helped okay
so do you think psychedelics that i just
mentioned earlier have a possibility of
going to these kind of
same kind of places of exploring
ideas that are outside of our um
more commonplace understanding of the
world
um in my yeah i think so absolutely
however i think we have to be really
careful about
those because young people or people in
general i should say
absolutely can get hurt by them i mean
but we get hurt by alcohol you know we
drive our cars and
we get kill each other um but
psychedelics are really interesting
because i know that
within the history of of our country
um we have used psychedelics in various
capacities for our military
in order to try to stimulate ideas and
access places and information
that can't be accessed normally this is
all
fact yeah i talked to matt for like
four hours so we ran out of time being
able to talk but i wanted to talk to him
about
mk alter and um ted kaczynski there's so
many
mysterious things there there's like
layers of
what's known and what's not known it's
fascinating but i think what is
interesting is psychedelics used that
were attempted to be used as
tools of different kinds that's the
point so like
we think of technology as tools
to enable us to do things in that same
way that
psychedelics like many drugs could be
used as tools some more effective than
others
absolutely i don't think what you i'm
not sure what you can do effectively
um with alcohol although
somebody i think somebody commented
somewhere on social media that uh
i don't know why everyone gives is so
negative about alcohol
because uh i think the person said that
um
it's given me some of the most
incredible it enabled me
uh to let go and have some of the most
incredible experiences with friends in
my life
and it's true we kind of sometimes say
alcohol is dangerous
it can make you do what but the reality
is it's also
a fascinating tool for letting go
of trying to be somebody maybe that
you're not and
allowing you to be yourself fully in
whatever crazy form that is
and allow you to have really deep and
interesting experiences with those
you love so uh yeah even alcohol can be
used as an effective tool for
exploring experiences and becoming uh
expanding your mind and becoming a
better person
so um what the hell was i talking about
uh so yes so so psychedelics and oh yeah
and mk ultra is there something
interesting to say in the
in our historical use of psychedelics
i mean think about it when did we start
doing that when did we start using those
that's true it's quite a long time ago
right
but okay but true but when did our
government start
experimenting with them with us okay our
government is the united states
government yeah
okay so that happened in around the
1950s
okay after quote unquote the 1940s
where we have 47 and we have you know
this
you know this roswell type stuff going
on okay like
crash sites and things like that so i
think that um
i think there might be a correlation
there i don't know what it is
okay but i do think fascinating actually
yeah there's
a lot of interesting things started
around that time period yeah yeah
and so aldous huxley would say we opened
the doors of perception
okay and what flew in
[Laughter]
oh man that was beautifully put
it'd be interesting to get your opinions
on certain more concrete sightings
that are sort of monumental
sightings with alien intelligences
in the history in the recent history
that at least i'm aware of i'm
i'm not uh very much aware of
this history but the most recent one
i've
spoken with david fravor on this podcast
i really like him as a person he's a fun
guy but also he's gotten the chance to
um he's described his account of having
experience with the
what he and others now termed the tic
tac ufo
what do you think of that particular
sighting which is captivated the
imagination of many
in particular because there's been
videos released of it
yes of these ufos but i find the videos
to be way too blurry and grainy to be of
interest to me the
personally uh to me the most fascinating
thing is the
first person account from david and
others
about that experience but what are your
thoughts those videos have been out for
a while
actually much i think in the mid 2000s
they were out
but what you have is you have kind of
like this corroboration
from a group and also the new york times
involvement
in 2017. my opinion about the tic tacs
is that
um first i believe the people
who have had the experiences i know some
of them like you know some of the radar
people
and things like that they saw them and
they're not
i don't believe they're making it up
okay um i do think that this is being
this is being used uh as a spin
okay and i'm just gonna say that and the
reason i think that is this is because
at the time it was released i was still
in touch with many people
who were among the ufo fight club and so
they had
intimate knowledge of these things and
the first thing they said was
um we have satellites that can read the
news on your phone when you're reading
it
so we've got better footage than this
and this is not
good footage at all therefore they
believe that it was
authentic footage that had been doctored
up now
why i don't know why um
so i so i honestly don't know if it's
accurate or not i mean
i believe the people absolutely but was
this something out there
to fool these people perhaps i don't
know
um is it spun um the people who i know
who are part of the ufo fight club
believed it was real
okay and said this is badly done but
real
okay i see but so there's some kind of
when you say spinning there's some
parties involved there oh yeah there's a
never tried to leverage it
from the for funds probably for funds
for financial interest yeah i think so
nevertheless it has inspired a
conversation
and just a lot of people
in the world that there's
something mysterious out there that uh
we're not
fully informed about and i was certainly
grateful that the new york times ran the
story right before my book came out
we'll see but there's the financial
interest that to me as a person who
uh doesn't give a damn about money
actually i don't like money
uh is um except
for when it's used in in the context of
a company to build
cool things but like personally i don't
know i find the financial interesting
side off-putting um
especially when we're talking about the
exploration of some of the most like
money is a silly creation of human
beings
i agree and it's it's uh
used to provide uh temporary like
the unfortunate thing with money is that
it um
helps you buy things that
too easily allow you to forget
the important things in life and also to
forget the difficult
aspects of life to do the difficult
intellectual work of being cognizant of
your immortality of
like fully engaging in life
in a life of reason too of thinking
deeply about the world all those kinds
of things
if you get like a nice car or something
like that and just like
i don't know all the different things
you could do with money is
it can make you forget that anyway as a
there's a long way to say that
yes yes it's very nice that it coincided
nicely with the book
but also it uh i think it
i mean like i said i think it inspired
quite a lot of people that
you know maybe there's a lot of things
out there that were
like it reminded a lot of people there's
things out there we don't know about
lex i can agree with you on that but can
i push back on two things
okay let's do it all right the first one
is that i was happy to receive
money from the book because of the new
york times article that's absolutely
false
so i published my book with oxford which
is an academic press
and you don't get paid with an academic
press okay so money was not it for me
what it was was recognition that my
research was being validated
so you know because then people called
me and said well maybe it's more than
interesting
okay and they did okay the other thing
about money is just as you say
that now i agree with you there
i'm upset about money too i think there
should be universal
health care uh a universal income all
you know i don't think people should be
in poverty especially because
we are so wealthy as a species frankly
um okay that said
think about this if you are if you don't
have money
you can't have a life of the mind either
right 100
so i'm not espousing that like money is
the devil i just think that
there is money can be um
a drug or i would compare it to like
food
or something like that where like you
really should have enough
to nourish yourself yes right and uh
too much could and too much can be a
huge problem
uh so that that's where i come from with
money and i'm just
uh aware i'm fortunate enough to have
the skills and the health
to be able to earn a living in whatever
way
uh like i wish of him being in the
united states and being able to speak
english so
at the very least i could work with
mcdonald's and my standards are
i told you i made a mistake i told joe
rogan
that i've always had a few money and
people are like oh
lex was always raised no no i was always
broke
what i mean by uh i've always had fu
monies
my standard what it takes to have a few
is
always very little i'm just happy with
with very little but yes
it's true that uh money for many people
and including for myself it's just a
different level for different people
is freedom yes freedom to think freedom
to do to pursue your passions
it just so happens i am very fortunate
that many of my passions
often come with a salary if i wished
right so
everything like me i love programming so
even just like
working as a like basic level software
engineer
would be a source of a lot of joy for me
and that happens in this modern
modern world to come with a salary so
yeah
it's it's definitely true i just mean
that it can be become a dangerous drug
so i'm glad
i'm glad you are in this pursuit that
you are in
for the love of knowledge and uh
but it's true yes uh people should
definitely buy your book
i won't be making money off of it today
oh yeah this rocks yeah
absolutely maybe my next book yes
yeah your sense is there's something as
there's some groups of people that may
be
trying to leverage this for financial
gains
and you know probably good financial i
mean they may have good reasons for this
too
like okay let's take the study of ufos
okay
maybe many people in government that
decide
who dole out the money let's put it that
way they think ufos aren't real
so they're not going to give these
programs money so how do these programs
make money
um they're going to have to find a way
to do it so maybe
that's how they do it okay so it's
fascinating this is a way to raise
money for for doing the research yeah i
think so
so let's take a step back to roswell we
talked about a little bit
what's your sense about that whole time
roswell and just
area 51 and the
sightings and also the follow-on
mythology around those sightings
um that's with us today all right so
where do i get started well i mean it is
a mythology here right
the mythology of roswell it's it's very
religious like in the sense that
if there's a pilgrimage to roswell
people make and
they go to there's a festival there as
well like a religious
festival um you could get little kitschy
stuff like you can get at a religious
festival there
so it's very much like a place of
pilgrimage where a herophony
occurred and a herophomy is basically
contact with non-human intelligence
okay so non-human intelligence is
thought to have contacted
humans or crashed at this place in
roswell new mexico
now what's fascinating is that i begin
my book
by going out to a crash site in new
mexico i have to get blindfolded
with um my well to tell you
the truth the story is that i'm with
tyler who's
an invisible and he wants to show me a
place in new mexico where a crash
happened
and he says that he thinks that i need
to see physical evidence because i don't
believe
and so i said i'll go but i'm going to
bring a friend of mine
and he said no you have to go alone he
goes it's a it's a place that is on
government-owned property and it's a
no-fly zone
and when you go you'll be blindfolded
and
i said i definitely need to bring a
friend
so he said well who do you want to bring
i just had met
this university scientist who's very
well known
and i call him james in my book and i
asked and i
had a feeling james would definitely
want to do this and i asked james and he
said i'll go tomorrow
okay so i suggested this to tyler and
tyler
said absolutely not you know and i
thought
i know he's going to look up james and
he's going to say yes because if anybody
can figure out what
this material is that we're going to go
look for it's going to be james
he has the instruments and so tyler did
in fact
look him up and finally said okay i got
you can go.
so we both head out there and we get
blindfolded and tyler takes us out there
it takes about 40 minutes
outside of a certain place in new mexico
so in terms of roswell this is what i
can say
is that according to tyler there were
about seven
crashes out in the 1940s in new mexico
in various places um
we went to one of them according to
tyler
i at the time i was completely an
atheist with regard to anything that had
to do with ufos
so we were out there we had specially
configured
metal detectors for these metals and
we did find these okay and
they've since been studied by various
scientists materials scientists so forth
and um i believe jacques talked about
not those particular ones but others on
the joe rogan show um there are no
anomalies so there are we scientists
don't i'm not a scientist so
i can't weigh in on whether i just
i just believe the people these people i
believe because
they're well-known scientists what do
you mean they're not anomaly so
no they are not they are not anomalous
oh and almost in terms of the materials
that
are uh naturally occurring on earth yes
okay so that so there's some kind of
inklings of evidence that uh
that something happened
in roswell in terms of crashes
of alien technology now what else is
there to the mythology so there's some
crashes right right yeah i mean that's
kind of epic
it's pretty epic yeah and uh
what else like what um what are we
supposed to take away from this
right yeah so it's weird okay so um
there's this okay so in religious
studies like i said we call it a
herophony
which is the meeting of a non-human
intelligent thing
whatever it is an angel a god whatever a
goddess
with or an alien with humans and that's
the place okay so the place is new
mexico
so we so new mexico becomes
folded into the mythology of this new
religion
is what i call a new type of religion of
the ufo
and it becomes ground zero for this new
mythology
just like mecca is the is the place
where
muslims go they have to go right at
least once in their lives
it's a pilgrimage place now so this is
so in my book that's how i
i tell it now what about roswell in the
public imagination
um obviously according to annie
jacobson who's good you know she's a
great author
investigative journalist she's written
about roswell too i don't agree with all
of
what she comes up with but part of it is
that there's a lot of military stuff
going on there
that is classified and there's a reason
why you can't get in
and nor would you want to right so um
so there's a lot of experimentation
going on there um
i don't believe that it's has to do with
et's frankly
but in the imaginations of americans
roswell is that place but i went to a
different place
and apparently there are several places
in new mexico now strangely enough
i travel back to new mexico at the very
end chapter
of my book but it's not it's i don't i
don't go there physically
i go there through the story of a
catholic
uh nun who actually believes that she
bilocated
to new mexico uh in the
gosh in the 1600s so she
yeah it was very strange and i was at
the vatican at the space observatory
when i made that connection that she
probably went to the very
well she believed she went to this very
place that i had gone
can you uh can you elaborate in a little
bit like what does it mean to go to that
place
yeah for for her i mean so we're kind of
uh breaking down
the barrier between what it means to be
at a place in time
right right i agree with you this is the
field of religious studies
so and again i don't say it's true in my
book i just say it's a very strange
coincidence
that i'm at the vatican observatory in
fact i'd finished my book
but while i was at the vatican
observatory i was there with tyler
and we were looking at the records that
can't they're called the trial records
but they're the canonization records
of these two saints each was said to
have done
amazing things one was joseph of
cupertino who levitated
okay or is said to have levitated the
other was
maria of agrada from spain their
contemporaries in the 1600s
who was said to have been able to buy
locate which is to be in two places at
once
okay so this is a belief in catholicism
that certain very holy people can do
these kinds of things like levitate
which by the way is also associated with
ufo abductions you know
people get levitated out of their beds
and things like that so we were sent
there
by a billionaire who was interested in
levitation and by location and since i
could get into the vatican and i knew
the
director of the vatican observatory both
tyler and i were able to go
to the secret archives and look at the
canonization records
and then go to castle gandolfo
which is about an hour from the vatican
where the first observatory
the space observatory of the vatican
is the second one is in arizona and it
has a much larger telescope
so we went and we and brother guy gave
me the keys to the archive
i said look at anything you want i got
to see a lot of stuff by carl sagan by
the way
i know you talked about yeah it was
awesome so they have a whole section on
extraterrestrial the search for
extraterrestrial life
and they don't by the way how awesome is
that it was awesome yeah
so we got to stay there they have a
scholars quarters yeah and so
they had two and so tyler stayed in one
and i stayed in the other
and brother guy probably shouldn't have
been so nice to me and given me the um
the keys because i i when i got home
we were there for two weeks when i got
home i got this frantic phone call from
him and he basically said
diana he goes do you remember where you
put the original
kepler and so i had this kepler right
and so i misplaced it
[Laughter]
luckily i remembered where it went i was
like oh gosh thank goodness i found it
but he'll probably change
the rules of the vatican observatory
after my visit
so maria is um she's actually in the
history of
our country in that she first wrote
a cosmography of what she said was the
spinning earth
and this was in the 1600s and she that's
her first book
and she wrote that and then she said
that she
was transported on the wings of angels
to the new world and she said that she
met
a culture of people and she
basically told them about the faith of
catholicism
okay and then what happened was that
the people that and she described the
fauna she described
the people and everything like that and
so there were actually missionaries
there
and when they went to try to um
convert some of the people who already
lived there
um apparently they already knew a bunch
of stuff and they said how did you know
this stuff and they said
uh this lady in blue came and told us
and they said did it look like this and
they showed them they obviously didn't
have a photograph
but they had a picture of a sister
a nun and they said yes they she wore
similar clothes but she was much younger
right
and these guys were you know thought
that was weird but when they went back
to spain
they found that this woman had been
doing that in her
mind had been traveling i mean i don't
know what to make of it there's so many
things that are sort of uh forcing you
to kind of
go outside of um you know i'm of many
minds i have a very
most of my days spent with very rigorous
scientific
kind of things and even engineering kind
of things and then
i'm also open-minded and just
the the entirety of the idea of
extraterrestrial life forces you to
think outside of
uh conventional boundaries of thought
scientific current scientific thought
let's put it that way
and your story right now is so exciting
it's freaking you out yeah
that's okay that's a nice way to put it
uh what do you uh
just another person that seems to be a
key figure in this
in the mythology of this is bob lazar
it'd be
interesting maybe there's others you can
tell me about but um
uh bob who's also been on joe rogan but
his story has been
told quite a bit that he's got i think
he
said that he witnessed some
of the work being done
on the spacecraft that was in
you know that was captured and so on in
order to
try to reverse engineer some of the
technology in terms of the propulsion
and so on
what are your thoughts about his story
how it fits into the
mythology of this whole thing and the
broader europologist
ufologist community okay so regarding
bob lazar
with respect to his claims um
again i have no way to adjudicate
whether or not he actually you know
encountered this i do have friends who
are and the people that i know
who know his story some
know him um believe him and
they have said to me that the most
important thing that they think he has
said
in fact one of them i think made it
made a meme out of it or something like
that was basically he said
uh maybe the public you know i regret
making it public maybe the public isn't
ready for this kind of information
and basically they've they emphasized
that to me
and they emphasized it so much that they
wanted me to know
right so that is somewhat creepy to me
so i think okay this poor guy bob lazar
so many people you know this is what
happens to people who have experiences
like this
they're questioned their reputations are
put on the line
in some instances their their
reputations are
manipulated on purpose to make them look
uncredible
to me as a scientist it's just
inspiring that it kind of gives this
kind of
i'm not even thinking of it is there an
actual spacecraft
being hidden somewhere and studied and
so on i'm thinking of it like
i don't know it's a thing that gives you
a spark of a dream you know
to as a reminder that
we don't understand most of how this
world works
and then we can build technologies that
aren't here today
that will allow us to understand much
more and that it's kind of like almost
like a feeling
that it provides and it inspires and
makes you dream
that's that's the way i see the bobbles
our story i don't necessarily people ask
me because i'm at mit people ask me like
did babazar
actually go to mit and so on i don't
know and i personally don't care
like it's uh that's not what's
interesting to me about
that story to me the myth is more
interesting
not interesting actually but inspiring
yes
because inspiring you're suggesting that
the myth inspires you to create reality
yes yeah i think that's that's true
so even if it's like not real it doesn't
matter
i mean in some sense just like you said
it does in some sense
it uh it doesn't so
a lot of people know how much i love
2001 space odyssey so
i got all these emails asking like
uh hey bro
uh do you know what's up with the
monoliths in like the middle of the
desert or whatever it was i don't i
haven't been actually paying attention i
apologize uh but
um you kind of mentioned offline that
this is kind of cool and interesting
what what do you make of these models
and in general are you um
are you a fan of 2001 space odyssey
where monoliths
showed up do you have any thoughts about
either the science fiction the mythology
of it or the reality of it
yes okay no okay
and please say more right so
first of all kubrick's films are not
ever easy for me
because they're so weird right and i
don't actually enjoy watching them
but yeah it doesn't take away from
their incredible brilliance though and
their visionary
uh merit so a 2001 space odyssey
is incredibly visionary
and of course all those things that
people say i don't have to restate them
um in terms of what i've it's a subtext
to my book by the way i i didn't mean it
to be
but it's almost it's almost a character
in my book 2001 a space odyssey
and when the monoliths started to appear
again
everything went crazy with my everything
internet social media
phone what's up what's going on right is
this disclosure
and i thought well you know i'll tell
you one thing is it's
let's look at the timing of it it's a
cool if it's an art
you know and then copy art and things
like that it's actually happening at a
really interesting time
when all of us are forced to go online
when all of us are forced because of
kovid right
we're completely now invaded by the
screen or we're invading the screen
like we're leaving our infrastructure
now is completely changed
so the monolith basically if art is
supposed to
like show us life it certainly has if
that's an art project somebody did an
awesome job with it
but apparently that monolith was there
for a long time right i mean that's the
thing it's been there for a couple years
so they said okay all right that said
um if your audience is interested
i think the best theory about the
meaning of the monolith
is um is robert eger or robert
ayer i think it's robert eger um he's
got a website where he does
analyses of films and it's called
collative learning or collateral
learning
and he does the meaning of the monolith
everyone should go look at that because
i fully agree with him one i studied
meet different meanings of the monolith
in 2001 a space odyssey
i was fascinated okay so what is this
about uh his
i accepted as soon as i listened to it
sue
and watched it so basically he says that
the monolith
is okay can you pick up your your phone
here
what does that look like
[Laughter]
looks awfully a lot like a monolith yeah
okay so basically that's what he was
saying
was that kubrick was basically the
monolith was
technology or the screen in particular
and he
basically was saying that the cinema
screen we're being you know completely
and if you think about it look at all
this we live in a screen culture we have
computer screens uh iphone screens or
you know phone screens
we have tv screens everything is
something you know and now that kovit
has come
we're forced to go into these screens
and we're forced to live
a different material existence than we
live have lived before
so in in my sense i think that if it's
an art project it's a really good one
for that so it's just i like that uh
that meaning of this it's a screen and
the screen could take all
all kinds of forms i mean uh our
perception system in a sense is a screen
uh between reality and our mind
this the screen of the computer is the
screen
the the virtual reality worlds that we
might be
one day living in it there will be an
interface i mean ultimately it's about
the interface
that's interesting it's an interface to
another
another world of ideas it's also a
material change
it's a change in our material i mean
when people talk about augmented reality
i say we already live in augmented
reality yeah don't we
because this isn't the this isn't our
grandparents existence
yeah like i sometimes you know you have
to pause and remind yourself how
weirdly different this reality is than
just even like
i mean 30 years ago the internet changed
so much
and social media has changed so much
about actually just the space of our
thinking wikipedia
changed so much about the offloading of
our knowledge
the way we interact with knowledge i
mean it offloaded
our long-term memory about facts
onto digital formats so in the sense
that expanded our mind
it's kind of interesting i'd i'd be
curious to see if he has just one
interpretation
i wonder if he corresponded with him yes
so
over the years he and i have
corresponded um and
i told him i said look i'm going to be
using this in my book so i think you
should read what i say
and he was he of course wanted to see it
so what do you think about your book
then you get it yesterday yeah oh yeah
so
um he is a non-believer in
alien intelligence and ufos but he
and that's fine but i i still agree with
him that the meaning of the monolith was
the screen
but that doesn't mean the screen isn't
like what david bowie said right so it's
not
exclusive so i could still use his
theory but differ from
the conclusions in terms of non-believer
and believer
there's um when you say believer
you also are kind of implying this um
the the idea that aliens have visited
or had made direct contact with humans
in some form
there's also the the exploration and the
idea
of just alien intelligent intelligence
is
out there in the universe you know the
drake equation
estimating how many intelligent
civilizations
may be out there how many have ever
existed how many are able to communicate
with us
i mean when you just zoom out from our
own
little selfish perspective of earth and
look at the entirety let's say the milky
way galaxy but maybe even the universe
does the idea that there are intelligent
civilizations out there
something that you're excited about or
something that you're
terrified about that's a good question
so basically i would say i'm not
so keen on it um i think
that our relationship with technology as
it is and as it
as i hope it will go will help us
survive okay um i don't think
we're equipped to do it as we stand now
but i think that if we can up our game
or
let's just put it this way if technology
is an extension of ourselves which it
actually is
it will help us because it'll probably
be smarter than us okay
it'll help us survive in the ways in
which it determines best
okay that said um if there
are non-human intelligences
out there and they have more advanced
you know obviously technologies than us
and they actually come
um uh the history of
human engagement with you know other
cultures
has not gone well for cultures
that are less aggressive
so you see what i'm saying like it's not
a good idea
well i wonder where we stand on the
where humans stand the full spectrum of
aggression
well heck where are we now lex i mean
we're not too great here we're still
aggressing against each other no i know
but that that will give us a benefit
right
like oh oh you're saying i thought
okay i see i just have a sense that
there may be a lot of
intelligences out there that are less
aggressive
because they've evolved past it we can't
assume that
no i know we can't assume that but like
if we can't assume it
then i'm gonna assume the worst
[Laughter]
well that's that's uh uh despite the
fact that i'm uh
russian and think that life is suffering
i tend to assume
not the best but i i tend to assume that
there is a best
core to uh to
creatures to people into creatures that
ultimately wins out
i think there's an evolutionary
advantage
to being good to other living creatures
and so uh ultimately i think that if
there's intelligent
civilizations out there that prosper
sufficiently to be able to
travel across the great expanse of
space that uh they've evolved
past silly aggression
that uh it's more likely in my mind to
be
deeply cooperative so like growth over
destruction
like growth does not require destruction
i think but if you see the universe as a
ultimately a place where it's highly
constrained in resources that are
necessary
for traveling across space
and time then uh perhaps aggression is
necessary in order to
aggress against others that are desiring
to get access to those resources
i don't know i tend to try to be
optimistic
on that front i think i'm emotionally
optimistic
and intellectually non-optimistic
uh yeah i guess i'm that i'm there with
you i i tend to believe that the uh
happiness and deep fulfillment in life
is found in that emotional place
the intellectual place is really useful
for
building cool new technologies and ideas
and so on but uh
happiness is in the emotional place and
there it
pays off to be optimistic i think
you said that technology might be able
to save us
uh you know that's also kind of
optimistic too
it might kill us there's uh talking to
you offline a little bit that
there was a sense that you know that we
humans are facing existential risks
that uh it's not obvious that we will
survive for long
do you have um is there
things that you worry about in terms of
ways we may
destroy ourselves or deeply damage the
fabric of human civilization
that technology may allow us to avoid
or alleviate yes i think that
any you can choose anything actually and
it could destroy us okay so you know uh
pollution
um you know here we're in a pandemic
okay
um a meteor okay so we can
use technology or the thing is
that we we say we use technology but
actually that's not
a correct way of putting it in my
opinion
um so there is a term used by
others uh coined by somebody i don't
know and i'm sorry to not give credit
where credit's due
but it's called technogenesis and it's
this idea
heidegger actually had this idea but he
didn't use that term and it's this idea
that we co-evolve with technology
that we don't actually use it most
people think it's like a tool we use
okay let's use technology to do this
well
actually when we engage with technology
we actually engage with it
and it engages back with us and we
engage with it so it's this co-evolution
that's happening
and in that sense um
i think that as we create
more autonomous intelligent ai
it will help us uh survive
because it you know if we co-evolve with
it
it will need us as much as we need it is
my opinion
um how that happens or if that
if that bears out to be true um
we'll see but i don't think the idea
that we use technology is
is a correct way to put it i think that
technology is something so
strange the way it is today like digital
technology i'm not talking about
hammers or things like that those kinds
of tools okay
is technology is so far removed from
that
and our environment is so now
conditioned by our technology and the
infrastructure we live within the
material structure
i think that um it's going to it's not i
don't think it's going to be a
frankenstein
i think it's actually going you know
like a mary shelley type idea of
technology i think it's actually going
to
be more promethean in the sense of
you know think about it we create
children and then
we get old and we rely upon our children
to help us
okay well i feel like that about
technology we've created well
we've created it right and so it's kind
of growing up now
[Laughter]
uh or maybe it's in its uh teenage years
and we'll see uh what what do you think
about
in terms of this co-evolution of um the
work around brain computer interfaces
and
maybe uh neurolink and and elon
seeing neurolink in particular
as uh its long-term mission as a
symbiosis with artificial intelligence
so
like giving a greater bandwidth
channel of communication between
technology ai systems and the biological
neural networks of our human mind
what do you think about this idea of
connecting directly
to the brain right in ai systems
i mean okay i've i've listened to
your podcast with elan i've listened to
elon before he's very intel
obviously super smart guy um i think
this is already
i mean not in the specific ways that he
is doing it
but i think we are already doing that
okay and i can give you some examples
um and there are really trivial examples
but they do make the point and this is
one of them
so before i started this
research on ufos and uops and technology
i actually was looking at the effects of
technology and in in particular
media on religion and what i did was i
was lucky
to be asked to be a consultant for
various movies
and one in particular i learned a lot
from and that was the conjuring
so i was a history consultant
for the conjuring it happens to be my
field it's catholic studies right
and you've got these people who are real
people and they're you know exercising
demons and things like that okay so i
thought
wow this is a great example for me you
know i didn't do it for the money
it doesn't pay well but i did it to
learn right so i work closely with the
screenwriters who
i work with now all the time with i work
with them all the time now
and what i found was this i found that
as the most interesting part of the
creation of this movie was the editing
process because they would use
the it would go through editing and they
would use test audiences
and a lot of the test audiences um would
be
like you know there's like these things
where they test their flicker rates and
things like that the eye flicker rates
and so and the uh and when it goes
really intense they go to uc irvine and
they do this thing called cognitive
consumption which is basically um
or i'm sorry cognitive consumerism
where they basically hook test audiences
up to
ekgs and they read their brains yeah and
they figure out which
scenes create the most arousal yeah
yeah and so they cut out all the other
scenes okay
so what we're getting is we're getting
like this drug when we go to the movies
or when we do video games when we watch
we're literally physiologically
responding
to our technologies so we're already
there we're already interfacing with
them
physiologically so that's my example now
the
the kind of thing that he's doing uh
musk is doing with neurolink
i say go for it that's awesome i hope he
does it you know
i'm fascinated i want it to happen um
why do i want it to happen
because i think that well first it's
inevitable that's it's going to happen
um i also want to point out that jacques
valet was trying to get this done back
in the 60s and the 70s he was writing
papers about in fact the arpanet
the proto-internet um was called
augmentation of the human intellect so
we've been doing this for a while okay
so um props to elon musk
but we've been thinking about this for a
good time um we've even been
visioning it okay so there was a
really interesting jesuit priest
he was french uh tell your deschardon i
don't know
if you know who he is if not he's
fascinating he was a he was actually a
soldier
uh before he became a priest and so he
believed he also saw what he called a
biosphere
now this guy is talking in like the
early 20th century like the 19
17 19 you know that time period and so
basically he
he said and wrote about this thing
called the newest sphere
and he basically said there will be a
point when we merge with our technology
and it's going to be somewhat like some
kind of a biosphere we have this
atmosphere
and then we have the stratosphere and
it's going to be this biosphere
and we're all going to be hooked into it
mentally so we'll be able to
communicate in a way in which we don't
communicate now
so you know that sounds so similar to
the singularity
so after i read him many many years ago
but when i read the um kurzweil's book
about the
singularity to me it read just like
um religious language like it read like
you know because he in fact it's so much
like
revelation to me when i read it that i
even assign it to my students in my
classes i'm like
this is this is it you know this is like
a really great book
of the singularity you know the coming
singularity and
um this religious event because it seems
like it when he writes about it he says
i felt it before i even understood it
you know
he i mean kurzweil kurzweil yeah chris
what i mean what are your
feelings about my feelings thoughts
feelings too about
the idea of the singularity do you think
it's ultimately the thing that echoes
throughout the history of ideas
is this like
moment of uh revelation like this
this almost mythological religious
moment
or is there something uh more
physical to this idea of concrete
concrete
about the idea of there'll come a point
where our technology there'll be like a
phase shift between uh
the the basic fabric of like humanity
of how we interact you know how
evolution brought us to be this
biological interaction that our
technology
uh crosses some kind of line of
capability
that the world be more technology
than human to where it will leave us
behind
sort of oh yeah i don't think it's going
to leave us behind i think it's going to
take us along
but it will be i mean i guess the idea
of the singularity first of all isn't
the idea of the singularities like we
can't possibly predict what's on the
other side of the singularity
these are the senses like this is like
the world will be fundamentally
transformed
yes okay so right and then it was you
know
um this was characterized in various
movies like lucy
and stuff like that uh you know lucy
being the first human
that right we so kind of replicating and
this is going to be the next
iteration of humans is the singularity
um
i actually don't believe that um frankly
however and the reason i don't believe
it is because we're material beings
and technology has to have a host so
we're not going to you know
become something super abstract like
there's it's just
impossible to do there's nothing like
that well people
would be listening to this podcast a
hundred years from now and laughing at
it because
they'll be all existing in a virtual
reality we'll be all information
uh as opposed to material meaning
connected to some kind of
concept of physical uh physical reality
i don't even know the right words to use
you see that's because there are none
because there's no place from there's no
view from nowhere
there's no non-material
like we have thoughts but they're
connected to us
right they're in our you know they're
somehow okay
as far as as far as you know listen
platonic forms i think is about as
as you know close to what we're talking
about as
possible like this place where these
things exist
and then there's like a physical
instantiation of it nope
the question is from the perspective of
the platonic form
what does our physical world look like
you know what i'm saying like uh
you know if if say you're a creature
existing in a virtual reality like
if you grew up your whole life
in a virtual reality game like what is
it
and somebody in that virtual reality
world tells you
that there actually exists this physical
world
and in fact your own you
think you're in this virtual world but
it's actually you're in a body
and this is just your mind putting
yourself and there's a piece of
technology
like how will they how would they be
able to
think of that physical world would they
would they sound exactly like you just
sounded a minute ago saying like
well that's silly who cares if there's a
physical world
it's the the entirety of the perception
and my memories and all of that
is in this other realm of um
of like information it's just all just
information i
why do i need some kind of weird meat
bag
to contain so there's a great again i
always
you know return to something for your
audience to read or you
um there's a great very short article
online for free by david chalmers do you
know him
he's the philosopher of consciousness
yeah interviewed him on this podcast
yeah
yeah yeah he's cool um
i used to i was friends with his best
friend for a while when
in when i was in grad school um he
probably has some weird friends he does
he's a philosopher okay so um
i like his fashion choice and his style
i'm gonna
hang out with him but it's a great guy
okay
so he wrote this article which i use a
lot i love it because it's
accessible to undergraduates and it's
called
matrix as metaphysics and basically it's
it's an answer to external world
skepticism
which is basically how do we know
there's an external world
right how do we know that we're not in a
matrix right now and so
um basically he's using he's he's also
he even references he uses a religious
reference even he says
you could think of the matrix of the
movie as
a new as the new um book of genesis
for our new world right and i thought
yeah that's absolutely correct
because you know we don't know
and we don't we won't know for sure or
for certain
therefore what we know is what is real
to us
and so he goes through these scenarios
and within
philosophy is called there's uh this is
different from that but it's like this
brain in a vat
right if you're a brain in a vat and
some
not so kind scientist is like recreating
this world for you just to see
you know and you think you're this
awesome rock star
right and you're living this awesome
existence but actually just this brain
in this vat okay but there's still a
brain in a vat
okay so his idea in um
the matrix says metaphysics kind of
takes out the brain in a vat like this
i don't know if this is possible so i've
read critiques of this
that you know what you're talking about
is a non-dualism like there's like um
you know or it's not necessarily a
non-dualism
um i just i mean information
in and of itself has to
have some kind of material component to
it i mean
it's that that that uh when taken
outside the realm of human beings
because dualism is kind of talking about
humans yeah
in a sense it's just possible to me that
there could be creatures that exist
in a very different form perhaps rely on
very different set of materials
yes that that may perhaps not even
look like materials to us yes i agree
which is why like
information it could be even in
computers
the information that's traveling inside
a computer
is connected to actual uh
material movement right right so like
there is
it is ultimately connected to material
movement but it's less and less
about the material and more and more
about the information
so i i just mean that there's it's
possible that uh
you think the singularity is basically
like
sloughing off our material existence
well i don't know
because i can tell you that this has
been the hope of philosophers and
theologians forever yeah well i don't i
think we're living in this thing
uh through a singularity i i don't think
i think this world
just just like as you've said already uh
has been already transformed
significantly and keeps continually
being transformed yes
and we're just riding this yeah we are
big beautiful wave
of uh transformation and uh
that's why it's both exciting and
terrifying
uh from a scientific perspective that
like
we're so bad at predicting the future
and the future is
always so amazing in terms of the
the things that has brought us i mean i
don't know if it's
always will be this exciting in terms of
the rate of innovation
but it seems to be increasing still and
it's really exciting it's it's exciting
yeah it's terrifying because obviously
we're building better and better tools
for destroying ourselves
but i on the optimistic side believe
that we
also can build better and better tools
to uh defend against all the ways we can
destroy ourselves and it's kind of this
interesting race of innovation yeah
books are great of course the greatest
book of all time
two of the greatest books of all time
are yours but besides those
what uh what books
technical fiction or philosophical
uh had an impact on your life or
possibly you think um
others might want to read and get some
insights from and what ideas did you
pick up from them
great okay i really enjoy nietzsche
okay so anything by nietzsche frederick
nietzsche he's a philosopher
um i actually hated him when i first
read him
in my early 20s that's like the opposite
of most people's experience right
they usually love them in their 20s and
then they uh
throw them to the curb later yeah yeah
i think he's totally misrepresented and
misinterpreted
he grew on you well it happened in one
night
so let me just describe it because it's
kind of funny yeah it happened on new
year's
so i had friends in when i was in my
twenties and they were kept they kept
telling me
you have to read niji you have to read
nietzsche and i tried okay
but again you know no i didn't like
i was not into how he described the
philosophical concepts he was trying to
get across
so but they would they weren't giving up
a very
um persistent friends so
one of them gave me um the gay science
and i had it on my book stand
and it was new year's eve and i'm
actually not a big
part i'm actually an introvert i'm a
geeky introvert okay
so i don't go out and party a lot it was
new year's eve even that couldn't get me
out to go party
so i just wanted to go to bed yeah and
new year's eve hit
and everybody went out and i was asleep
and they woke me up and i was like darn
they woke me up ah might as well read
this book by nietzsche
okay so i picked it up and lo and behold
i turned to a page that was exactly
about it was called
sanctus januarius which is basically
saint january
and it was about new year's eve and i
thought whoa what a weird coincidence
and it was a really real it was also
super catholic and it was a really
beautiful little aphorism it's actually
a book of aphorisms
which are kind of religious right and so
he
it's really just uh the genre is
religious let's put it that way but he's
not
so basically he says today is the day
when
people are supposed to make these
resolutions right and he says
from here on out i will will never say
no i will only say yes okay i look away
if something's horrible i'll just look
away from it i won't get angry at it
and then he also says i will be like
saint january and saint january
is actually the saint whose blood is in
this
place in italy i think it's in italy or
and um and
every year it turns it turns to blood
again so it's like
it's desiccated it's you know it's just
this miracle it says
my blood is now um it flows again
and i was like wow that's really
beautiful and i said and a strange
coincidence because it just turned
you know 12. so it's like new year's eve
i pick up the book
i read this aphorism i said strange
coincidence that
and then i turn the page and the page is
about coincidences
and i was like i said it and i thought
this is weird
and i felt like they was alive i felt
like the book was alive and nietzsche
was speaking to me
i had a like experience and engagement
with nietzsche yeah
and so after that i couldn't put his
stuff down
it was engaging fascinating everything
so yeah so that's one book
yeah the gay science what did what did
you pick up from from
the gay science or from niche in general
because there are some ideas yeah yeah
the idea is basically that um truth
he's got awesome one-liners you know
so truth is a woman so okay what is
what does he mean by that truth is a
woman basically she's going to lie to
you
she looks real attractive yeah but she's
not going to tell you the truth
[Laughter]
so okay so basically i'm not saying that
that's true about women i'm obviously a
woman
so he's so basically what he's saying is
that truth
is not is like what i said uh brother
guy said
it's a moving target okay we started
this whole conversation
with what's real right so i should have
just gone straight to nietzsche have it
not you heard truth as a woman
you know okay so truth is a woman yeah
all right so that
and also and you know foucault this um
other philosopher french philosopher
actually
takes up this idea and creates his own
framework called genealogy from it so
the genealogy of morals
so that we only believe certain things
and we we sediment
them into truth so we say you know
truth told who said that was it lenin or
stalin
a truth told enough times i mean
a lie told enough times becomes the
truth yeah so that's basically nichian
right there
okay see that's nietzsche so nietzsche
also is a huge
critic of christianity um which i'm
actually catholic i'm a practicing
catholic so i
appreciated his critique i thought it
was actually quite accurate
and he's a critique of religion in
general and
and he's fascinating and also i find
that his he talks about
altered states of consciousness and he
calls them elevated states
and he i think through his book you can
actually experience elevated states
so um yeah nietzsche
[Laughter]
thumbs up so what what other books yeah
okay so hannah rent
she is a philosopher that not a lot of
people know about
but she was a jewish woman during the
holocaust and she was in turn
interred at bergen-belsen which was
uh basically auschwitz for women and she
escaped
she came to the united states and she
had worked with heidegger even though
he's supposed to be
anti-semitic and a nazi and everything
but they were lovers
okay so she comes out and she's at
columbia university and she teaches
philosophy there
and she writes this she writes two books
which i'll recommend
one is called eichmann in jerusalem
where she attend attends the nuremberg
trials
and she basically makes this really
astute observation about evil
and she says eichmann is one of the
people who sent the jews to the
concentration camps who ran the trains
okay
um and she said the thing about eichmann
was that he didn't seem particularly
evil actually he seemed to be quite
a nice guy she said what was interesting
about him was he seemed
incredibly thoughtless and stupid and
she said and he used a lot of
stereotypes
like memes so she actually wrote about
memes before we had them
and now people just use memes and
they're actually used against us even
there's even a segments of warfare
called memetic warfare
all right so memes are something that
can sway a whole population of people
um so she wrote about memes before they
were even in existence
and that's eichmann in jerusalem and i
think she also has some really amazing
things to say about evil
is that um when people remain
thoughtless she has another book called
the life of the mind which is gigantic
and i don't
think anybody will read it but frankly
it's one of the best books i've ever
read
and i've read it many times and
basically the life of the mind and the
life of the mind she asks a very simple
question
she says why do people do bad things why
are they evil
and what she says is she wonders if it's
she says that
bad people sleep well at night contrary
to you know how the saying
how do you sleep at night well that's
only because you're a good person that
you're asking that question
because you actually have a conscience
and a conscience is this dual
kind of you fight with yourself about
the consequences of your actions
and she says bad people don't seem to
have a conscience
so they actually sleep well at night and
so she goes through a whole history of
philosophy
uh about evil and that's really a good
one too but i have um
i also have to recommend this one too
there's one more so i know i recommended
two but just from the same philosopher
my friend jeffrey kreipel he's at rice
university and he's in my fields right
uh religious studies
he wrote he's written several books i
mean he's written a heck of a lot of
books let's put it that way
but he's um his i think his best book or
the one that impacted me the most
is called authors of the impossible and
his book is
his writing is very much like
nietzsche's writing in the sense that
he it's almost as if he reaches out of
the pages and he grabs you
and kind of slaps you around and says
think about this you know and you can't
help but be
changed after you've read it and he's
got a great chapter in there about
jacques valet
oh so he colors a bunch of different uh
thinkers and authors that
are outs that somehow are what is it
renegade in some aspects of
revolutionaries yeah they're thinking
the impossible
uh there's a great one he's written
called mutants and mystics
where he talks about the comic strips
uh the um gosh why can't i remember the
name of the person
he just died stan lee he talks about the
history of the comics by stan lee
and they're all paranormal they all
start off super paranormal
and it's fascinating um on the topic of
anna arendt yeah connor hannah
uh so i haven't read her work but i've
vaguely touched upon sort of like
commentary of
her work and it seems like some people
think her work is dangerous in some
aspect i don't know if you can comment
on
why that is i just it it feels like
similar with iron rand or something like
that yeah like this is
i should say not dangerous but
controversial yes it is yes
they think it's controversial um this is
the reason i believe um i've heard of
the controversy
the controversy is that she didn't i she
first of all
um she is jewish and she did escape
a concentration camp and yet she's
called she's been called anti-jewish
and i think part of that was that she
basically was saying
something that i believe
that a lot of normal people
are like eichmann and evil things are
done by people who just follow the rules
and they don't think about what they're
doing and that's one of the most
pernicious forms of evil of our time
so we talk quite a bit about the
definitions of religion
and what are the different building
blocks of religion so one of the
i don't think we touched on we did a
little bit with the afterlife but
in a sense i don't know if you're
familiar with ernest becker work and all
the
philosophies around there about the fear
of death and
how the fear of our own mortality
awareness of our mortality and its fears
in case of ernest becker
is a significant component
in the psychology in the way we humans
develop
our understanding of the world so
what are your thoughts
in the context of religion or maybe in
the context of
your own mind about the role of death in
life
or fear of death in life and
are you afraid of death
[Laughter]
we cover everything in this every single
topic is covered
wow okay um
i so happen to have benefited perhaps
from living with an older brother who
seemingly had no fear of death while
growing up
and he did everything okay
so he was he climbed mountains he was a
rock climber
he jumped out of airplanes of course he
had to be a green beret and go into the
special
forces where that type of thing is a
requirement right and so because of that
i did a lot of things outside of my
comfort zone
and which probably i shouldn't have done
and hope hope to goodness
my kids don't do them yeah okay
okay so do you so i do i fear death um i
think about death a lot actually
um you may not know this about me but in
my field
i was the head i was the co-chair of the
death panel
it's called the death panel though it's
like it's the
panel to think about death in religious
studies
um and i was at for many years so you've
thought about it a bit
a bit let's see i think that people are
a little too confident
i think about life in general that
they're gonna kind of live
all the time and not die i happen to i
mean i hate to say it
i'm super positive and most people would
consider me to be
too happy almost right and so it's odd
then that
i spent a lot of time thinking about
death but i wonder if there's a
connection there
yeah i'm happy to be alive right that's
kind of what the thinking about death
does is it makes you appreciate the days
that you do have
yeah it's it's a weird controversy i i
tend to believe that
um the fact that this life ends gives
each day a significant amount of meaning
so i don't know uh it seems like an
important feature of life it's not like
a bug it seems like a feature
that it ends but it's a strange feature
because i wish it
like all the good stuff you wish it
wouldn't end well you know it's
interesting
lex and i do point this out to my
students because we cover
in a lot of the basic studies courses i
teach
we cover all religions or as many as we
can like the major religions
and so you take hinduism for example um
now this is an ancient religion okay so
you and i are here talking about how we
enjoy living in life and things like
that
well the goal of hinduism is basically
never to get reincarnated again
is basically to not live okay and to get
off samsara which is the wheel of life
and death
so escape the whole yeah exactly can
think of that
conditions are so different that you and
i and my students are happy to be alive
but they're back in the day you know
thousands of years ago
when they wrote when they actually
didn't write it they spoke the vedas
which were the sacred traditions of
india they wanted off they didn't want
to come back
life was terrible that's what people
don't have the
adequate understanding of history that
for the majority of people
life is really hard right and you and i
are
and your audience among the lucky
yeah that we actually life like life we
want to live
most of the time yeah most of the time
wha what do you think uh
the biggest since we're covering every
single possible topic let me ask the
biggest one
the unanswerable one from the
perspective of alien intelligence
or from the perspective of religious
studies or from the perspective of just
diana
what do you think is the meaning of this
existence
of uh this life of ours yes okay
so all right so
[Laughter]
well of course i have to my
philosophical training
as uh undergrad always makes me
think about like what's the assumption
in your
your question the question there's an
assumption there it's like there is a
meaning
okay that's the assumption by meaning
what do you mean by life yeah you define
the terms
no no but listen okay i'll answer your
question i'm just going to say that
there's this
assumption that we should have meaning
to life okay well maybe we
we shouldn't maybe it's just all random
okay however
i believe that it's not and in my
opinion and the meaning of life
in my opinion is intrinsic i enjoy
living i want to live sometimes i don't
enjoy a living
and when i don't enjoy living i change
my circumstances
so it's intrinsic and i think that
certain things are intrinsic and
like love love of your children is kind
of um
well it's actually physiological but
it's also intrinsic it's beautiful
you know there's something about it that
that is
intrinsically um desirable
so that i i think the meaning of life is
like that intrinsically
desirable so it's something that just
is born inside you based on
um what makes you feel good
no that's hedonism that's about what
where do you place love love love of
your children
yeah so basically um love of your
children by the way is not
always easy because they do things that
they shouldn't do you have to discipline
them that's one of the worst things
about parenthood to me
is disciplining my children i don't like
to do that i love them
um so a lot of things that i
do that i feel are good
are not easy so there's an intrinsic
sense
that like okay let's take um
animals okay so we have dogs and cats
okay so you might not but i do i've
you know i told you about them can you
can you uh share their names if i share
their names i will share their names
okay
so we have a cat and it has red fluffy
hair
and so we called it trump well when we
got our dog
we figured that it needed a companion so
we called it putin
so we have trump and putin that's the
greatest pet names
of all time i'm sorry this
and uh maybe we'll be able to share a
picture of your cat because this is
awesome
it is really cute yeah very photogenic
uh i mean is this something that's
uh whether la uh whether we're talking
about love
or the intrinsic meaning do you think
that's
something that's really special to
humans
or if there is intelligent alien
civilizations out there
do you think that's something that they
possess as well
maybe in different forms like whatever
this thing
that meaning is this intra intrinsic
drive that we have
do you think that's just a property of
life
of some level of complexity that we will
see that everywhere in this universe
in my opinion and this is just my
opinion um i
i do think that it is but i also think
that it can take different forms
so if there is like uh think of gravity
right gravity kind of like
makes stuff stick to it right it like
tracks stuff
well what is loved you that does that
too right so people who
are cr we call them charismatic charism
it means love charism means light and
love
so a charismatic person is a person who
attracts people to them
like the sun does right like you know so
um
so i think that whatever this property
is that's intrinsic
is like gravity and most likely takes
different forms
in different types of life forms yeah i
can't wait until
like uh albert einstein type of figure
in the future will discover that love is
in fact one of the fundamental forces of
physics that would be cool
diana this is one of the favorite
conversations i've ever had
it's truly an honor to talk to you and
uh
thank you so much for spending all this
time with me absolutely it's been fun
thank you
thanks for listening to this
conversation with diana walsh basalka
and thank you to our sponsors element
electrolyte drink
grammarly writing plugin business wars
podcast
and cash app so the choice is health
grammar knowledge or money choose wisely
my friends
and if you wish click the sponsor links
below to get a discount and to support
this podcast
and now let me leave you with some words
from carl sagan
somewhere something incredible is
waiting to be known
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time